So Leute, ich habe jetzt erst nur das Mikrofon angemacht, um euch erstmal ins Ohr zu husten.
Excellent.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz mein Mikro entwirren.
So, da sind wir.
Also, ähm, ich habe mich gerade nochmal eine Stunde bewegt.
Sachen gibt es sogar zweimal am Tag heute.
Bewegung, was ist da los?
Bald ist nicht mehr Pipo Fett angesagt.
Ähm, weiß man was heute Neues vorgestellt wird?
Ja, wahrscheinlich iOS 6.
Äh, nicht iOS 6, wie komme ich auf iOS 6?
iOS 14.
Äh, der Switch auf die AMA-Architektur wahrscheinlich.
Neues macOS vielleicht.
Mal gucken.
Also, was ich sagen wollte, ich hatte echt Schiss, das Event zu streamen, weil die sind bei, ähm, auf Twitch sind sie dieses Jahr, also aktuell, also eigentlich seit dieser und letzter Woche,
sind sie ja besonders scharf drauf, was Copyright und sowas angeht.
Deswegen habe ich schon überlegt, okay, soll ich das streamen sein, sein lassen?
Oder, soll ich vielleicht streamen und nur labern und es nicht zeigen?
Allerdings war ich dann eben mal auf Twitch und habe bei, äh, bei TriHacks gesehen auf Twitch, dass TriHacks einfach mal ex, auf exzellente Art und Weise, äh,
äh,
dass er auch, äh,
Apple streamt.
So, und wenn TriHacks Apple streamt, dann kann ich auch Apple streamen.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein absolut nerviges Overlay?
What the fuck?
Ich, ich kann das nicht mal wegklicken.
Geht das von alleine weg?
Ah, excellent.
Was ist das für ein Bullshit?
Braucht doch kein Mensch, oder?
Zumindest er streamt das auch und wenn TriHacks das streamen kann, dann darf ich das auch streamen.
Wir müssen mal schauen, wo es schneller ist.
Ob das Stream hier aktueller ist, oder, äh,
oder hier aktueller, müssen wir mal schauen.
Ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass die ganzen Avatare hier,
alle,
extrem hipster aussehen?
Da sieht einer mehr hipster aus, als der andere.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Fehlt bloß auch, dass sie auf, auf,
Elektroroller kommen.
Das wär's jetzt noch, wenn Tim Cook auf einen Elektroroller reingefahren kommt.
Das ist im Simbao, ist ja schon zu divers.
Das ist mir,
ist mir alles egal.
Ich, ich,
ich find's bloß,
ich find's bloß lustig, dass die alle so extrem hipster aussehen in den Avataren.
Guck mal, wer, wer, wer streamt denn den Kram hier grad noch?
WWDC.
Äh.
Hallo?
Twitch, es ergibt keinen Sinn, dass ich nach WWDC suche
und TriHacks nicht finde.
TriHacks hat im Titel stehen,
WWDC.
Warum finde ich WWDC nicht, wenn ich danach suche?
Only Miss G-Baden.
Okay, er hat's groß geschrieben.
Schreibt mir in die Kommentare, wenn ihr das nicht findet.
Ah, im oppose.
Ah, okay, jetzt findet er's.
Okay, guckt mal, Leute.
So viele, wie das hier streamen sollen,
da kann ich das auch streamen.
Guck mal, sogar links hier streamt.
Ja.
Sogar er streamt hier.
Die streamen alle.
Dann streamen wir das jetzt auch.
Letztes Mal war auch okay,
aber letztes Jahr hat sich Twitch noch nicht so eingekackt,
was Copyright anging.
Dieses, seit, seit zwei Wochen
sind die ja voll, voll, voll
durchdrehen btw wir haben noch ungefähr eine halbe
stunde zeit bis es losgeht ich muss nebenbei noch mal kurz was
was futtern ja du darfst du vom apple gerät streamen das haben sie ja
glücklicherweise abgehört also wwdc predictions gucken wir uns mal an was es
da gibt reddit reddit predictions weil wir wissen ja dass reddit prinzipiell
most accurate ist bei sowas also reddit macht da nichts vor gefolgt von twitter
natürlich nur getoppt durch den twitch chat jetzt wieder bullshit bingo es gibt
einen excited counter es gibt einen excited counter aber ich bin mir nicht
ganz sicher wie weit wir den einblenden wir können das in der osx vm anschauen
das ist big brain das problem ist nur ich habe die osx vm gelöscht weil ich
sie für nichts gebrauchen kann und 60 gigabyte plattenplatz auf
der ssd weggenommen hat siri os liebe ich veräppeln siri oder so schwachsinn gibt es
da nicht hier show results all reddit results new predictions so richtig geschrieben also
irgendwie gibt es da nichts hier predictions our predictions das haben wir schon gelesen was da
was die prädikten ich war ein apple wird sich natürlich wieder selbst feiern ohne ende wenn
das einer kann sich selbst feiern dann ist es apple ich warte noch auf die kamera mit mit
auf die iphone kamera mit mit vier objektiven oder fünf objektiven oder am besten noch unten
und oben ein objektiv oder sowas 360 objektiv vor jetzt das hier das da bestes apple
für twitch was es gibt besser als bit22 hat quasi alle funktionen die betreut tv hat plus
mehr und besser integriert der franke z frank hey face oder sache aber noch jung aus der farbe
fräses faces hat und morgen war er was heißt zwei streamsutor morgen war er noch ziemlich
kurzer stream oder wie man es auf hessisch sagen würde ein kurzes stream war dass ein kurzes karren
und ziemlich kurze streben habe gehört cook will mit einem purzelbaum das event
eröffnen ich kann mir nichts besseres vorstellen
nicht kurze kurze ein kurzer kurz kurze nicht kurze das t das tz weder nicht
betont und kurze warum bindet wird steht nicht einfach offiziell ein weil twitch
gerne kontrolle über die emotes hat und gucken ob gucken wollen ob die in ihr
monka toss passen und bei ffz und beta twitch tv kann jeder fast alle seiten
reichen was kann man bei ffz dagegen machen das
nicht alle emotes angezeigt werden du musst bei der twitch tv emotes
explizit aktivieren und du musst animated gifs explizit animieren
ich bin aber auch ganz froh dass twitch da nicht das sagen hat stellt euch vor
twitch hätte bei ffz und bei der twitch tv emotes das sagen dann würden manche
emotes nicht reinkommen zum beispiel würde das hier twitch garantiert nicht
genehmigt
oder kliv applied emotes dass man die quantitas anDC Tiravical im
glaubt auf im resultwater günstiger потому but also found off bedroht
by bei es ist bei bei klips ist es ja auch gar nicht erlaubt die gesichter es
mag jetzt erst mal widersprüchlich klingen das ist nicht erlaubt die
gesichter bekannt also existierende personen zu nehmen also du kannst jetzt
dich also고
mit Bildern von
Mitarbeitern von Twitch
oder von Channel-Besitzern auf Twitch,
das ist was anderes. Da ist die rechte Situation
aber geklärt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt
habt mit dem Lull-Emote. Ich meine, ihr kennt
alle das ursprüngliche
Lull-Emote. Das war das hier.
Auf Twitch ist es jetzt
das hier. Und warum ist das
so? Weil TotalBiscuit
nicht alle Rechte
hatte an seinem eigenen
Face. Und wie kann das
sein, warum hat TotalBiscuit nicht die Rechte
gehabt an seinem eigenen Gesicht?
Weil er nicht das Foto gemacht hat, sondern jemand
anderes das Foto geschossen hatte.
Und deswegen musste Twitch das
Emote nachmalen und konnte nicht das
ursprüngliche Lull verwenden.
So gestört ist es mittlerweile
mit Copyright schon.
Welches NAS...
Was? Welches war
nochmal das Board mit Onboard-CPU,
was du für NAS empfiehlst?
Also wirklich...
Also wirklich empfehlen,
kann ich nix. Also ich kann
dir sagen, was ich hab. Das hier...
Äh...
Wo ist es denn? Das hier hab ich.
Chat, ihr macht das Copy-Pasta
nicht richtig.
Das geht anders.
Poki, wie? I'm safe. Da fehlt
der Virgin-Check davor. Nicht mal
richtig Copy-Pasten kann der Chat.
Das ist echt schlimm.
Das hab ich
als aktuelles NAS-Bild.
Wobei ich es halt nicht so wirklich empfehle.
Es war halt wirklich ultra low-budget
NAS, was ich da gebaut hab.
Bin mal gespannt, wo die früher am Start
sind. Hier oder hier?
Oder hier? Oder bei Trihacks?
Oder bei hier?
Okay, er ist schon am Start
hier. Er ist schon am
Start.
By the way, ich kann mir seine Videos beim besten Willen
nicht angucken. Ich find das so
anstrengend, ihm zuzuhören.
Jeder wie er mag, ja. Aber ich find's
ultra anstrengend.
Ähm...
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde,
wo ich noch ein bisschen Schiss habe, ist
labern die alle nur
oder zeigen die auch das Event?
Wenn die das Event zeigen, ich guck mir das
an, wie das Trihacks macht, dann zeig ich auch
das Event. Moin, Nekorock.
Äh, der Ochoid
HC2, der ist nicht so gut.
Äh...
Achso, der HC2. Ja, das hab ich auch.
Das ist, wenn du so ein Fix und Fertiges
haben willst. Das ist auch gut, ja.
Wenn du keine
10G-Performance brauchst,
so nach dem Motto, dann ist das okay.
Ja, ich hab das schon zu einem Apple-Event
gemacht, aber die sind ja dieses Jahr
besonders pingelig, was Copyright angeht.
Ich komm mir voll
ausgestoßen vor, wenn ich die ganzen
Apple-Avatarer mir angucke.
Die sehen alle so hip aus.
Also, ich
müsste mir da zumindest mal
entweder so ein richtig
Anubis-Bart wachsen lassen, das ist auch
ziemlich Hipster. Kennt ihr das? Das ist so
grad voll angesagt, so Anubis-Bart.
Ähm...
Oder wenigstens ne Klatze oder so.
Pippo-Fett.
Das bin ich, genau. Ich sitz hier am Notebook.
Leute, ich bin dabei.
Ich spiegel mich im MacBook.
Fuck. Ich muss die
Emotes hier wegmachen, weil ich wette mit euch,
es gibt Leute, die
stören sich da dran, dass ich
die Emotes da drüber mache
und dann sage, ich mag keine
Leute, die so aussehen,
weil ich die Emotes da drüber mache.
Was an Anubis-Barts?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das heißt.
So ein spitzer Bart
halt.
Ihr wisst doch, was ich meine.
So.
Der so
spitz ist.
Ne, kein Ziegen, so ein richtig
so eine lange
Keule, so.
Okay, wir gucken mal. Hipster-Bart.
Was gibt's denn da alles?
Ja, sowas hier.
Sowas hier meine ich.
Das ist richtig hipster
So geht das
So was müsste ich mir wachsen lassen
Dann wäre das wenigstens okay
Ja bei dem sieht das gut aus
Der hat das auch ultra ordentlich geschnitten
Ja da ist es ja auf den Millimeter genau
Was sagt eigentlich Trihack Stream
Oh 5 Minuten WWDC
Was sagt es bei ihm
Hatte Heise nicht auch einen Stream
Heise WWDC
Hatten die nicht auch einen Stream
Okay Leute
Wenn die Restreamen mache ich das auch
Ich sehe das nicht ein
Dass ich der einzige bin der sich da dran hält
Glaubst du der O-Droid H2 Plus
Ist gut genug um ein
Sophos Home drauf laufen zu lassen
Ich habe keine Ahnung
Was eine Sophos Home ist
Also irgendeine Firewall
Mit Zusatzfunktionen
Aber ich habe keine Ahnung was das alles kann
Was das macht, was das für Anforderungen hat
Legit keinen blassen Schimmer
Was kostet es denn überhaupt
Wow Moment man braucht
Man braucht einen Account
Um sich was zu installieren
Ich finde bei FFZ wirklich nicht die Option
Für Better Twitch TV und Animated
Ich zeig es dir
Ich zeig es dir wo es ist
So gehen wir mal hier in Chat
Ah ne ich bin nicht angemeldet
Oh ich glaube FFZ ist gerade kaputt
Kann das sein
Also FFZ
Konnte man das nicht mal größer machen
Gut wird eben auch sein
Du suchst jetzt mal nach GIF
Da ist es hier
Addons
Better Twitch TV Emoji
Und dann sagst du Enabled
Es kann übrigens sein
Wenn du Better Twitch TV Emoji nicht hast
Dass du noch ein zweites Addon
Für Better Twitch TV Emoji installieren musst
Aber ich glaube
Ich glaube das haben sie mittlerweile mit eingebunden
Weil ich habe auch nur eine Sache installiert
Ich bilde mir ein
Das haben sie mit eingebunden mittlerweile
Hm
Vielleicht musst du das auch in FFZ machen
Ja aber du brauchst zumindest
Dieses Menü hier
Und dann kannst du die Animated GIFs einschalten
GIF
Oder wie die coolen Leute jetzt wieder sagen würden
Wobei es nicht GIF heißt
Sondern GIF
Die Emotes bei ihm sind teilweise auch
Lul
Ey mein
Lestream
Pogers
Pogers Lestream
Also
Okay die streamen alle
Dann ist mir wurscht
Dann stream ich auch
Jetzt ist es so
Easy
17 Minuten geht's los
So Leute nebenbei esse ich mal kurz was
Ähm
Warte mal ganz kurz
Ich bin gleich wieder da
Was zu trinken holen
Das dauert ja ein bisschen
So
Und erstmal Klimaanlage anmachen
Hier drin ist übel warm
Gestern habe ich übrigens voll verkackt mit der Klimaanlage
Ich bin ins Bett gegangen
Hab mir gedacht ah busy warm ist es
Lässt mal 10 Minuten die Klimaanlage laufen und machs wieder aus
Und was hab ich gemacht
Klimaanlage angeschaltet
Und nicht gesehen dass sie auf heizen steht
Und ich hab schon gedacht irgendwie geht das Ding nicht an
Was ist da los
Bin ich mal aufs Klo gegangen
Und als ich wiedergekommen bin
War es keine Ahnung gefühlt 28 Grad im Zimmer oder so
So und dann habe ich zum ersten Mal festgestellt was passiert
Wenn man die Klimaanlage
Von Heizen auf Kühlen
umschaltet. Das verwirrt die
Klimaanlage. Da knackst sie nämlich.
Hab umgeschaltet
und dann hat die Klimaanlage erstmal
gemacht
Bonk AS.
Was jetzt? Hab ich erstmal ausgeschaltet,
5 Minuten gewartet und wieder
eingeschaltet. Und dann ging's.
Dann hat sie wieder runtergekühlt.
Exzellent.
Auf wie viel Grad
stellst du es zum... Die Gradanzahl ist das
gleiche. 22 Grad
hatte ich eingestellt.
22 Grad. Aber die Klimaanlage
macht immer erstmal so
2-3
Minuten lang, dreht die immer erstmal
relativ hoch
und dann regelt sie runter.
Wahrscheinlich muss die... Wahrscheinlich kann die
nicht
lauwarm anfangen, sondern muss erstmal das
Heizding anschmeißen und kann
das dann erst nachher regeln oder so.
Was hast du für eine Klimaanlage?
Ich... Moment.
Mitsubishi
Z
Warte mal.
Klima
Z
Ach du Scheiße, wie heißt denn das Ding?
M?
Äh
Z. Irgendwas mit... Ah ja.
Ja, ja. Sowas hier.
Sowas hier hab ich. Genau sowas hier.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es exakt
dieses Modell ist, aber genau diese Geschichte.
Ich hab außen an der Wand so ein Teil
hängen. Das kann heizen und kühlen.
Und innen
hab ich im Arbeitszimmer so ein Ding
mit Fernbedienung. Im Schlafzimmer hab ich so ein Ding mit
Fernbedienung.
Einen Umfragevorschlag
erhalten.
Äh, John hat eine DVD, das versteh ich nicht.
Das ist mir zu bigbrainig.
Die brauchen
ordentlich Leistung. Ja gut, kann ich alles haben.
Erstmal Hände waschen, Leute, falls ihr grad von draußen
kommt.
Ah, jetzt hab ich den Witz
verstanden. Oh, da ist Painschamp.
Äh, also dass ich so ein Teil an der
Wand hängen hab, juckt mich überhaupt gar nicht.
Time
until WWDC. Äh
Der ist over
time.
Ich frag mich, ob die alle das Event zeigen.
Ob ich das Event zeigen darf. Ich will
wissen, was die hier alle machen.
Wie sieht das bei Heise aus?
Heise zeigt das ja auch nicht.
Wir werden es ja spätestens in 2-3 Minuten sehen,
wenn es losgeht. Oder spätestens,
wenn die Pre, äh, wobei, guck mal,
die haben hier auch eingeblendet.
Was kostet die Installation von so einer
Klimaanlage? Ich krieg's ehrlich
gesagt nicht mehr zusammen, was der Kram gekostet
hat. Ich glaube,
ich glaube, ich hab irgendwas
um 2000 Euro bezahlt.
Könnte auch ein bisschen mehr gewesen
sein, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Was frisst so ein Ding an Leistung?
Äh,
nachdem ich grad unten meinen Stromzähler
nicht laufen hab, kann ich's dir grad nicht sagen.
Also den Stromzähler, den ich mir gerade nicht sagen kann.
Den ich auslesen kann von hier oben, der ist grad nicht
angestöpselt. Ich hab ja im Keller
einen ESP32 hängen,
der sowohl den, den, den, den ollen
Drehzähler als auch den
oberen, fürs obere Stockwerk ausliest.
Der ist grad nicht an.
Le stream!
Okay, Leute, die restreamen
alle das Event. Alle.
Die restreamen echt
alle. Warum sollte ich den Kram nicht
auch restreamen? Mit 2000 Euro
ist man gut dabei. Es, wie gesagt, es könnte
auch ein bisschen teurer gewesen sein, aber ich glaube,
2000 Euro hat das gekosten, gekostet.
Aber ich hab die Klimaanlage
ja auch meistens nicht durchgängig laufen.
Ich mach das immer so, wenn's mir zu warm wird,
mach ich das Ding an,
ähm, dann lass ich das meistens 20 Minuten
laufen und wenn's mir dann anfängt zu ziehen,
mach ich wieder aus.
Und das hält dann eine Weile.
Also zumindest, wenn's nicht so extrem
warm ist. Ähm,
im Sommer, also wenn's richtig heiß draußen ist,
36 Grad plus, mach ich manchmal so,
dass ich im Schlafzimmer, also auf ganz
Kaltstelle, die Klimaanlage, die Tür
offen lass und die Klimaanlage volle Pulle
abends mal zwei, drei Stunden laufen lass,
weil dadurch wird das komplette Haus
kühler. Nicht kühl, aber kühler.
Greta weint, das mag
sein.
Aber das ist mir wurscht.
Ob die weint.
Solange ich nicht schwitze,
wohl wein ich zumindest nicht.
Ist euch mal aufgefallen, wie wenig
sich die Leute jetzt für Umweltsachen
interessieren auf einmal? Davor,
bevor Corona und Gedöns
am Start war,
war Umweltszeug, da ist
der Weltuntergang am Start gewesen.
Und jetzt interessiert's keinen mehr.
Vor allem, als wär's jetzt nicht, äh,
als wär's jetzt weg.
Das ist doch genauso schlimm wie vorher.
Solaranlage kaufen, dann lohnt sich
so eine Klimaanlage richtig. Ja, da bin ich
tatsächlich gerade dabei.
Angel, nein, da bin ich gerade dabei.
Ich hab in
zwei, drei Wochen kommt einer,
ich weiß nicht genau wann, ich glaub,
mal gucken,
äh, ich glaub hier,
irgendwann, kommt einer von
den Stadtwerke und
erklärt mir, was es Geiles gibt
dafür. Neun Minuten,
ja. Ja, aktuell ist es ganz
gut für die Umwelt, weil da vieles runtergefahren ist,
aber danach wird's eher, eher schlechter.
Bitte mit Speicher, klar.
Klimaanlage ohne Batterie oder ohne
Akku ist doof.
Das ist ja keine Batterie mit Akku, das ist, das ist
bescheuert, das lohnt sich nicht.
Bekommt man noch Geld fürs Einspeisen? Ja, aber ich weiß
nicht, wie wäre sich das, wie weit sich das noch lohnt.
Sind wir hier Fanboys oder Hater?
Das kann sich jeder selbst überlegen.
Naja, ist aber witzig, ne?
Dies ist, vorher
Umweltgeschichten voll angesagt,
kam Corona, interessiert kein Mensch mehr.
Vor allem, als ist es, als ist es
in irgendeiner Art und Weise besser geworden.
Auf lange Sicht. Ähm,
aber ich glaube, dass ein bisschen, ein bisschen
eine Sache spielt da mit rein.
Warum es jetzt, glaub ich, weniger Leute
interessiert, weil viele festgestellt haben,
oh fuck, so reich sind wir gar nicht,
weil nach fünf Wochen Corona,
haben wir alle kein Geld mehr.
Ob das dann so eine gute Idee ist, dass wir komplett die Umwelt
im Alleingang retten? Aber ich bin,
ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, dass das eines der wichtigsten
Themen ist, worum sich die gesamte Menschheit
kümmern muss. Ich, ich bin ja
schon froh, ich bin, ich bin ja schon froh,
dass es kaum noch welche
gibt, die sagen, äh,
Klimawandel oder, oder generell
Klimaproblematik existiert
nicht. Das war vor ein paar Jahren noch anders.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren noch anders. Da gab es noch genug, die
gesagt haben, nee, nee, das ist alles, äh, ausgedacht.
Mittlerweile stellt sich ja nur,
nur eher die Frage,
also, dass es Probleme gibt,
bestreitet kaum noch einer.
Heute, aktuell, ist ja eher
die Problematik, wo sich so
ein bisschen der, der Streit
dran, äh, entzündet,
ob da jetzt, äh, der
Mensch viel Einfluss drauf hat oder nicht.
Oh. Also das ist
ja gerade so die, die Sache. Und das
ist auch wieder, äh, auch wieder ein Punkt, wo ich
mich auch permanent drüber aufregen könnte,
wenn da diskutiert wird.
Ähm, auch wenn
ich persönlich der Meinung bin,
dass es relativ,
nämlich, also, dass
die Indizien sehr stark
dafür sprechen, dass wir was dafür
können, mit unserem Lebensstil
der letzten
40, 50 Jahre angefangen,
ähm, finde ich trotzdem wichtig,
dass man sich auch mal kritische
Punkte anhört, wo Leute sagen,
okay, ha, vielleicht
gibt's da noch ein paar andere Aspekte,
aber das geht ja gerade nicht, ja.
Wenn irgendjemand öffentlich sich hinstellt
und sagt, ja, äh, Klimawandel,
ich bin der Meinung, äh, der Mensch
kann da gar nix, bla bla bla, aus diesen, diesen
Punkten, der wird ja medial, äh,
gesteinigter.
Das, das sorgt nicht dafür, dass
Leute, die der Sache
eh kritisch gegenüberstehen,
irgendwie ihre Meinung ändern.
Ja. Aber trotzdem,
ich find's gut, wenn man die Leute mal zur Sprache
kommen lässt. Sollen sie sich doch mal auslassen, ist doch okay.
Ich mein, ups, ich will nicht nach
I suchen, wer weiß, was ich da finde.
Ich mein, es gibt immer wieder Berichte, so nach dem Motto,
ähm, sogar, sogar, ähm,
Nobelpreisträger,
äh, hätten Kritik
am menschgemachten Klimawandel.
Hey, sollen sie doch, lass, lass sie doch
einfach mal ihre Punkte vorbringen, wo ist das Problem?
Wie gesagt,
ich bin persönlich der Meinung, es liegt total auf der Hand,
dass wir dran schuld sind, ähm,
aber, warum
sich nicht mal auch andere Standpunkte anhören,
da stirbt doch keiner von.
Aber zum Glück, zum Glück
sind wir mittlerweile, es hat sich ja die letzten Jahre schon ein bisschen
was getan, sind wir mittlerweile alle
auf dem Stand, ähm,
dass zumindest keiner mehr sagt,
gibt es gar nichts. Das ist ja
schon mal gut, weil vor ein paar Jahren
gab's noch genug Leute, die gesagt haben, gibt es gar nicht.
Ja, äh,
PlayerRedOne bis zu einem gewissen Grad,
aktuell ist es so, dass du, äh,
wenn, wenn du
irgendwas nur halbwegs als Mainstream bezeichnen
kannst, dort definitiv
keiner der Kritiker zu Wort kommt, das
finde ich schlecht.
Und wenn da einer zu Wort kommt, wird da medialer,
äh, komplett fertig gemacht,
oder in irgendwelchen Diskussionsrunden
gnadenlos niedergeredet, sogar vom Moderator
selbst. Ähm,
das finde ich in allen Bereichen übrigens nicht gut.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, ob's hier gleich losgeht.
Wie sieht's bei TriHacks aus?
Guck dir eine
komische Fitness-App an.
Wie sieht's hier aus, wie sieht's hier aus?
Ich will wissen, ob die restreamen oder nicht.
Restreamen?
Alter, wenn die nicht restreamen,
restream ich auch nicht.
Ich will wissen, ob die restreamen.
Also, wenn das,
Leute, ich sag euch, wenn das nicht erlaubt ist,
wenn das
restreamen nicht erlaubt ist,
dann laber ich nur, und ihr müsst
den Stream selbst aufmachen.
Oh, geh mal fort.
Mit F.
Was ist das hier?
Ich hab schon mal ein Apple-Event restreamt,
ich weiß, ich weiß.
Aber dieses Jahr sind sie, was Copyright angeht, besonders
scharf, äh.
Heise, Heise restreamt, ja.
Ach, ich dachte, das ist ein Counter, das ist eine Herzrate.
Ich, ich, ich guck, was die anderen machen.
Ey, wenn die anderen streamen auf Twitch,
die anderen großen Streams, also restreamen,
restream ich das auch.
Wäre das nicht gut für Apple, wenn du restreamst?
Klar.
Überall, wo sie Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, wo sie sonst keine bekommen würden,
wär nice.
Was macht Heise so?
Ah, ja, ja, wen haben sie da dabei?
Excellent.
Oh, oh, ich hör was, Leute.
Äh.
Wo kommt das Sound her?
Ah, ihr habt gar keinen Sound.
Der Sound kommt bei mir vom zweiten Browser-Tab.
Lull.
Was wird denn heute vorgestellt?
Man weiß es nicht so genau.
Okay, Leute, ich guck, wie die anderen das machen, äh.
Wenn, wenn die auch nicht restreamen, dann laber ich auch nur.
Ah, ne, okay, die restreamen.
Okay.
YOLO, who cares?
Die haben 2000 Zuschauer, äh.
Wenn das nicht erlaubt ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht.
Keck, W.
Der restreamt auch, okay.
Ne, ne, ne, dann, dann, dann restream ich auch.
Dann, dann, dann laber ich nur, dann restream ich auch.
Chris Donahanch, neun Monate, exzellent.
Heise ist auch dabei.
Die Twitch-Suche ist mega fail, Alter.
Warum findet man das nicht?
Lustig eigentlich.
Echt fail, dass man das nicht findet.
Okay.
Gleich geht's los.
Weil eben laggt das Stream.
Die zeigen das auch, warum läuft das hier übrigens nicht weiter.
So.
Schau mal.
Schau mal mal.
Was da rauskommt.
Wir müssen gleich die Lautstärke.
Oh, Leute.
Es geht los.
Ne, she baited.
Triax streamt auch, gut.
Dann.
Apple stellt flache Erde vor.
I Earth.
Ah, das Feuer.
Jetzt geht's los.
Okay.
looked.
Hey!
Jennifer Katzt.
Und du.
13 어제 abgetroffen dass das Projekt ste coordinator für uns sea- shake zu seinem
wm von 14 zu die bdc
mothersolid ist in unserer
disziplin
Apple, unsere Entwickler und unsere Anbieter.
WTF?
Es ist hier, dass wir einige unserer größten Innovations-
Das ist erst und erst. Fuck!
Das ist, warum wir glauben, dass es so wichtig ist, WWDC dieses Jahr zu haben.
Und obwohl es sich hier ohne dich nicht so fühlen kann,
kann ich dir versichern, dass wir ein großes Show vor uns haben.
Dieses Jahr bringen wir die Konferenz in einem ganz neuen Weg
für alle von euch um die Welt direkt zu eurer Wohnung.
Und wir wollen euch zu unserer Wohnung hier bei Apple Park begrüßen.
I'd like to first talk to you about two big things that are happening in the world right now.
To start, I want to address the topic of racism, inequality-
Oh, jetzt kommt das Thema hier auch schon.
and to recognize the pain being felt throughout our nation,
especially in our black and brown communities after the senseless killing of George Floyd.
And while the events of this past month are sadly not new,
they have caused us to face longstanding institutional inequalities and social injustices.
This country was founded on the principle of freedom and equality for all.
For too many people and for too long, we haven't lived up to those ideals.
We're inspired and moved by the passionate people around our nation and around the world
who have stood up to demand change.
It was all aimed far higher to build a future that lives up to our ideals.
This means taking action.
Two weeks ago, we announced Apples racial equity and justice initiative,
with a commitment of 100 million dollars.
Starting in the United States and expanding over time,
this initiative will challenge systemic barriers that limit opportunity for communities of color
in the critical areas of education, economic equality, and criminal justice.
We also announced something important for this community,
the new developer-entrepreneur camp for black developers.
We want to do everything we can to foster the brightest lights and best ideals.
Ah.
Oh, excited.
Ihr müsst für mich mitzählen,
Excited Counter.
Ich habe den Excited Counter verkackt.
Zwei. Zwei.
Excited. Zwei.
Excellent.
Craig am Start.
Ah, ich finde das toll, dass die Brust
zu sehen ist.
Die Brustbehaarung von Craig sehe ich gerade.
Das war klar.
Damit hat jeder gerechnet.
Over the years, we kept the fundamentals
largely the same, but carefully added
features. Like folders for
organizing your apps.
Ben, ich benutze ihn nicht. Benutzt das jemand?
And personalized experiences powered by
on-device intelligence that serve up
just the right thing at just the right
moment. Ich habe fünf Homescreens, keine Folder.
It's hard to imagine an iPhone without these features now.
Well, that brings us to this year.
We're doing more on our iPhones
today than ever before.
So we've rethought some of the core elements of iOS
to reflect this.
Jetzt kommt's.
Quick peek.
Eine Uhr.
What is happening?
Sudoku.
Äh.
Ah, Desktop Widgets.
Desktop Kachel Widgets.
This is going to be amazing.
Let's dig in, starting with the home screen.
Today's home screen worked great, but as we get more
and more apps, we can end up with this.
Lots and lots of pages.
And we tend to forget.
So sieht's bei mir auch aus.
Wouldn't it be great?
If there were a way to organize all of those apps
without doing a thing?
Well, this year we're doing just that
with something called the App Library.
It's a new space at the end of your home screen pages
that automatically organizes all your apps
in one simple and easy to navigate view.
Da sagt gleich noch Machine Learning.
Machine Learning gestützt.
Das lassen die sich nicht nehmen.
AI-Folders.
Now, like you, I have muscle memory built
for the first page or two.
But when it comes to all of these pages,
well, honestly, I've lost track of where a lot of things are.
And that's where the App Library comes in.
You can see that all of my apps are automatically organized here.
In fact, now with the App Library,
I actually don't need all those pages for all my apps.
So we created an easy way to hide app pages.
I just go into jiggle mode,
tap the dots at the bottom...
Moment, das heißt offiziell jiggle mode?
...of all my app pages.
I can simply tap to hide the pages I no longer need.
Just like that.
And now with those pages hidden, App Library is always just a swipe or two away.
So here in App Library, getting to the app I'm looking for is really easy.
Up at the top, I have the search field.
And I get all my apps organized from A to Z.
Now over here on the upper left, I have suggestions.
It uses on-device intelligence to show me the apps that I'm looking for.
And on the right is recently added, giving me access to the apps that I've recently downloaded from the App Store.
And below are intelligently curated categories.
So I can tap into a category, like Apple Arcade, and see all of my apps in that category.
Now let's go back.
You may notice that in each of these categories, the apps I use most are right here at the top level.
So I can launch one of these directly with just a tap.
So that's App Library.
We think this is going to make it easier than ever to get to your apps.
Next, let's turn to Widget.
Aha.
Okay.
Also, Apple Watch geht voll an mir vorbei.
Ich meine, dass man ein Widget resizen kann, ist jetzt ja nun wirklich keine große Errungenschaft.
Ah, das ist gut, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Das finde ich gut.
So smart.
AI-kontrolliert, Smart Stack.
Excellent.
Ich hoffe, man kann das Workflow automatisieren.
Geht das nicht jetzt schon?
Leuchtet!
Boah, krass.
Was, nicht jetzt schon?
Das geht doch jetzt schon.
Ach, auf dem iPhone.
Ah.
Exzellent.
Okay, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Man kann es ein- und ausblenden.
Hoho.
Bei YouTube wird es nicht gehen.
YouTube kannst du klicken.
YouTube schaltet den Kram explizit ab.
Premium, Alter, YouTube Premium.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Ich habe Siri aber aus.
Das ist besonders großartig, wenn es Informationen gibt, die du auf dem Bildschirm referieren möchtest.
Zum Beispiel könntest du Siri zu deiner Kaffee-Liste hinzufügen.
Das ist also das neue Siri-Design in iOS 14.
Aber die UI ist nur Teil der Geschichte.
Um dir mehr darüber zu erzählen, wie wir Siri smarter machen als je,
schicke ich es an Yael Garden.
Danke, Craig.
Siri wird immer smarter und immer mehr hilfreich.
Ich bin sehr gespannt, die neuesten Updates mit dir zu teilen.
Siri hilft dir in vielen kleinen Wegen.
Jeden Tag.
Das sagt nichts aus.
Das ist...
Das brauchen wir alles nicht, Chat.
Das ist nur für Lowbrain-Leute.
Okay, das ist cool.
Das finde ich gut.
Weil es geht jetzt auch schon, aber jetzt ist es besser.
Nee, Kosta.
Ich war...
Ich warte drauf, bis die ersten Leute sich auf die Fresse hauen,
weil Google Translate oder Siri Translate mistranslated hat.
Trench, ah, yes.
By the way, it's so private, dass du es zu Apple schicken musst, erst mal zwischendurch.
Nice to have, nice to have.
Wir müssen es jetzt nicht übermäßig flamen.
Nice to have ist es auf jeden Fall.
Translate will make communicating between languages easy.
Wollen wir das mal?
Danke.
Dankeschön, acht Monate.
Ja, das übertreibt man nicht.
Es ist nice to have, das war's.
To tell you more, here's Stacey Lysik.
Thanks, Craig.
First, let's get started with conversations.
From the beginning, messages was designed to make it really easy to get to your newest messages.
But with so many active conversations, sometimes it can be tough to get to the ones that are most important to you.
So we are introducing a new way to let you stay connected to your most important conversations.
AI-Conversations.
Blockchain.
So you can always get to them.
And you can see messages as they come in with a beautiful animation on the pin.
Next, let's talk about expressing yourself with Memoji.
Doch, doch kein AI.
There are over 1 trillion ways to customize your identity with Memoji.
In iOS 14, we're adding even more ways to create your look with over 20 new hair and headwear styles to let you reflect your hobby, profession and personality.
We've also added something that's even more relevant today.
Face coverings.
And we're adding...
Oh, es gibt jetzt Mundschutz.
My favorite way of using Memoji is with Memoji stickers.
Mundschutz-Emojis.
And now we have three brand new Memoji stickers that let you send a hug, a fist bump or even a blush to your friends.
Last, let's chat about groups.
When you're talking to a group, sometimes there's so much going on, it can be hard to keep track of the conversation.
So this year, we're gonna help you bring order to the chaos.
AI.
First, we're adding inline replies that let you reply directly to a specific message.
Das ist gut.
Das ist echt praktisch.
Or you can view them as their own thread, so you can focus in on the specific topic.
To make it even more clear who a message was meant for, we're introducing mentions.
With mentions, you can just type someone's name to direct a message to them.
Chat ist doch egal, ob das WhatsApp schon kann.
Das kann's doch nicht.
...when you're mentioned in the group conversation.
And check out the top of this conversation.
We have an all new design for how groups appear.
It lets you see all the members of your group where the most recently active people are.
...where the most recently active people are.
And first time ever you can create a unique visual identity for your group by setting a group photo or customizing your group's look with an emoji.
Gut, das passt.
Inside the conversation you see group members' photos around the image.
Of course it looks great as a pin.
You know who's most recently commented in the group because their photo will appear around the outside of the pin.
And that's what's coming to messages in iOS 14.
All new pinned conversations.
Fun Updates to Memoji
All new Pinned Conversations
Geil, du kannst was oben anpinnen
Unglaublich
Ich hoffe, das kommt noch
Ich hoffe, das kommt fürs alte iPhone SE noch
Heutzutage
Also, bisschen sowas wie Street Views.
Who the fuck ist Michael Grothaus?
Oh, jetzt AI.
Wir brauchen mehr AI.
Chat, ihr seht schon, warum die sitzt.
Was richtig cool wäre, wenn die mit ihrer Uhr den Stuhl steuern könnten.
Dachte schon, der grüne Punkt.
Wie das?
Wait a minute, das konnte Maps noch nicht?
Das konnte, echt, das ging nicht?
Das kann Google Maps wirklich schon ewig.
Okay, also Deutschland juckt da wirklich keinen in dem Fall.
Pfff.
Was ist denn Range Anxiety?
Ach so, dass das mit dem Elektroauto nicht ausreicht.
Für den Akku.
Ah, ja das ist praktisch.
Das ist gut.
Danke, Meg. Und jetzt geht es weiter mit dem CarPlay.
Das ist die Transformation der Fahrer-Erfahrungserfahrung für iPhone-Händler,
indem sie die smartere, sicherere Art und Weise sind, wie sie ihre Autos lieben.
CarPlay ist überall. Und es ist unglaublich populär.
Hier in den USA gibt es es an fast jedem neuen Auto.
Und weltweit gibt es es an über 80% der neuen Autos, die verkauft werden.
Mein Opel Agila 2001 kann das nicht.
Für so viele Leute.
Die Leute lieben CarPlay.
Und wir bekommen sehr passionierte Reaktionen.
Joanna Stern sagt, dass es ihr Leben unendlich besser macht.
Wir haben großartige Updates für iOS 14.
Zuerst haben wir neue Wallpaper-Optionen.
Perfekt für das Auto.
Und wir geben Unterstützung für neue Kategorien von CarPlay-Apps.
Parken, EV-Anbieter und Quickfood-Anbieter.
Oh geil!
Quickfood-Anbieter, endlich mal eine Funktion für mich.
... mit dem Rethinken von Autokarten.
Sie sind seit über 100 Jahren da.
Sie werden groß, gering und reif für das Wiederentdecken.
Um euch mehr zu erzählen, was wir geplant haben,
gehen wir in die Garage mit Emily Schubert.
Danke Craig.
Ich freue mich, ein digitales Auto zu vorstellen.
Jetzt könnt ihr eure Klamotten zuhause lassen
und euer Auto mit eurem iPhone starten.
Und das erste Auto, das wir unterstützen,
wird das neue 2021 BMW 5 Series.
Ich zeige euch, wie es funktioniert.
Es ist super einfach.
Es nutzt NFC.
Und ihr klickt einfach auf Unlocken.
Und ich setze mein Handy auf das Chargingpad
und drücke dann auf Start.
Aber das geht nur noch über das, was BMW dafür bezahlt hat.
Digitale Klamotten haben Sicherheitsbedürfnisse.
Sie leben in dem sicheren Element eures iPhones.
Und wenn es missgeht,
könnt ihr eure Klamotten via iCloud automatisch auswählen.
Sie sind sogar einfacher zu teilen als eine physische Klamotten.
Kopien entwickeln keine Reise zum Verkauf.
Und ihr könnt von eurem Auto mit iMessage teilen.
Gebt Craig eine Klamotten,
damit er nach Hause fahren kann, nachdem wir hier sind.
Wenn ihr ihn teilen möchtet,
könnt ihr Optionen einstellen,
wie ein restriktierter Fahrerprofil,
aber auch zwischen den Fahrern.
Das ist unnötig,
aber wir geben Craig vollen Zugang.
Vollen Zugang?
Danke, Emily.
Das neue BMW wird nächstes Monat für die Kunden verfügbar sein.
In addition to adding this feature to iOS 14,
we're also enabling it in iOS 13,
so customers can use their car keys even sooner.
Of course, we want this to work in any car.
So we've been working on standards with industry groups.
And this is just the beginning.
We're working on technology that will leverage our U1 chip,
which uses ultra-wideband technology for precise spatial awareness.
So you'll be able to leave your iPhone in your bag or pocket
and still securely unlock and start your car.
We expect to see support for this standard
starting in new cars next year.
Now let's turn to the App Store.
Twelve years ago, you revolutionized the industry
with the launch of the App Store.
Today, we have so many amazing apps
that offer a rich set of experiences.
We can truly say that for everything we want to do,
there's an app for that.
So now it's time for us to extend the success of the App Store
and make apps available and accessible in whole new ways.
You could have the right app you needed at just the right moment.
Let's look at what it would be like if you did.
Today, no matter what you want to do, there's an app for that.
But what if you don't have the app you need right when you need it?
Like when you need to pay for parking?
Well, now there's an app clip for that.
Ooh, look, a new coffee shop.
There's an app clip for that.
Or your friend sends you a message with a print you like.
That would be nice.
Looking for somewhere to eat nearby?
App clip.
I'm very health conscious of you.
Hey, there's a scooter.
Let's take it for a spin.
Yup, app clip.
Mmm, ice cream.
Wait, there isn't one for that yet?
Well, soon there could be an app clip for that.
And that.
Yeah!
Do do.
An app clip is a small part of an app.
It's light and fast and easy to discover.
So you can quickly get what you need right when you need it.
Everything about app clips is designed for speed.
They start with this card, which quickly pops up.
And with just a tap, you can launch the app clip.
You don't need to enter credit card numbers, because app clips can be used to pay for payments.
And you don't have to mail it on your account, because it can take advantage of sign-in with Apple.
App clips won't clutter your home screen.
And will only stay along as long as you need them.
But you can easily launch recent used app clips from the new app library.
It's always easy to download the full app.
And this makes app clips an easy way to discover more of what the app store has to offer.
And discovery is key.
App clips are brought up in the apartment app at the moment you need it.
So it's a great way to make them really easy to come.
App clips can be easily discovered.
And launched from the web.
You can launch app clips from messages when friends share them with you.
When you want to order take-out from a restaurant in maps.
You can launch an app clip right from a place card.
You'll be able to tap on NFC tags out in the world.
I fucked up the Excited Counter. I can't fit it in.
Or you can scan QR codes to launch app clips that work with products you purchase.
The best way to discover app clips will be with a new Apple-designed app clip code.
So when you see one, you'll know that there's an app clip waiting for you.
They incorporate both the visual code and NFC.
So you tap on them or scan them with a camera to bring up an app clip.
App clips will be great for businesses that already have apps.
But we want to be able to use app clips everywhere.
Including smaller spots that may not have their own app.
So we made it possible for apps like Yelp, which support multiple businesses,
to create app clip experiences for each of the places they work with.
Developers will create app clips from a part of an app
using Xcode and the full power of the SDK.
To ensure that they launch quickly, they'll need to be less than 10 MB in size.
And that's app clips.
Immediately discoverable.
Small in size so they launch fast.
Integrated Apple Pay for easy payment.
Sign in with Apple for quick and privacy-friendly login.
And the option to download the full app from the App Store when you want to keep it around.
We can't wait to see all the app clips developers will create.
And that's iOS 4.0.
It's a huge release that transforms the core experience of iPhone.
With redesigned widgets right on the home screen.
And a new way to organize your apps with the app library.
It adds incredible updates to some of the most popular apps
with powerful improvements to messages and maps.
And introduces a whole new way to tap into apps with apps clips.
Picture in Picture is top.
Das finde ich gut.
Das ist auf iOS.
Auf iOS für iPhones kommt.
Da ist jetzt James Bond am Start.
Oh hey, we made it.
Alright, well let's jump right in.
iPadOS builds on all the amazing features of iOS.
While adding unique capabilities that deliver a distinct experience for iPad.
Oh, jetzt kommt iPad.
Markup and illustration.
A reimagined trackpad experience that lets you interact with iPad.
Das braucht derjenige, der für mich Twitch-E-Mails macht.
Also niemand.
Haha.
Und auch kein Scanner in iPad Pro.
All of this combines to put iPad into a class of its own.
iPad excels at every type of input.
And is a product to do anything and everything.
Which brings us to this year and our new release.
iPadOS 14.
Let's start with experience.
This year, iPadOS delivers unique, made for iPad designs.
That take great advantage of the iPads large multi-touch display.
Now iPad has always been about the apps.
In the beginning, we focused on giving the ecosystem of iPhone apps a larger canvas to deliver new and unique experiences.
This quickly sparked an entirely new set of apps, designed for iPad first, with immersive experiences that transform this magical sheet of glass into whatever you needed it to be.
We're proud of the over one million apps on the App Store today, designed just for iPad.
With customers continuing to push their iPads further than ever before, we're extending the design language of iPad to make apps more streamlined and more powerful.
To give you a live look at these enhancements, I'll hand it over to Josh Schaffer.
Thanks, Greg.
Let's take a look at some of the enhancements to iPadOS.
The first thing that you'll notice are the same redesigned widgets that you saw in iOS 14.
They look great on iPad as well.
They give you information at a glance whenever you go home.
But let's see some of the improvements in the apps, starting with photos.
iPad is the perfect device for browsing your photos.
Its large canvas lets you immerse yourself in all your favorite memories.
And this year, we're making it even easier to browse and organize your photos with an all-new sidebar.
With just a tap of this button, I can reveal the sidebar, with all the core functionality of the app in a single location.
My photos remain front and center, but now I can quickly tap to move between parts of the app.
The sidebar is a really powerful way to organize your photos, too.
I can easily drag and drop the photo to the sidebar, and then just drop it to add it to an album.
We've brought this sidebar to many apps across iPadOS.
Let me know where it provides quick and easy access to all your folders.
And files, where we've consolidated navigation into the sidebar for a streamlined new design.
We've also streamlined the toolbars, adding new drop-down menus that consolidate functions
into a single easy-to-access button.
I can just tap to change views like this.
And for even quicker access, I can just tap and drag to change the sort order, all in a single motion.
You'll find this same approach across other apps, like Calendar,
where we've brought controls into a single toolbar at the top,
providing more space for your content and single-review-wide lists to access all the app's functionality.
Finally, music has been updated to take even better advantage of iPad's large canvas.
The sidebar in music makes it easy to move between views.
I can quickly jump between the new Listen Now and my playlists.
And once I start playing a song, I can bring up the brand-new full-screen player,
where I can see rich album art, transport controls, and lyrics, all in one single view.
And these are just some of the enhancements that are coming to apps in iPadOS.
We're really loving these new app designs, but there's more, starting with Siri.
Noch mehr!
The new Siri design that you heard about in iOS 14 is especially useful on iPad.
Results appear at the bottom right corner, allowing you to easily reference the app while using Siri.
And we applied this same approach to other parts of the experience, like calls.
Now today when you receive a call on iPad, you see this.
Whatever you were working on is suddenly completely covered with the incoming calls, right?
Not cool.
Wouldn't it be nicer if instead you saw this?
Ja.
That's much better.
Tatsächlich wäre das besser.
Now an incoming call is presented with a compact notification that doesn't take you out of context.
And you can simply tap to answer or flick it away to dismiss.
And this applies to all calls, including those from your iPhone or third-party VoIP apps like Skype.
And of course we're bringing this to iOS as well.
We think our iPhone customers are going to love it.
Now there's one more key experience we've redesigned for iPad this year.
And that's search.
Okay.
Today search is a full screen experience and sometimes you can lose track of your context.
So we've redesigned search with a new compact design.
You can start a search from anywhere, like the home screen or over any app.
And this makes it easy to find what you need without feeling like you've left the app you're working in.
But we didn't just redesign it.
We've rebuilt search from the ground up to be universal.
Becoming the single destination where you can start all of your searches.
First, we made it better than ever as an app launcher.
You just start typing a few characters and you can instantly get to where you're going.
It's also great for finding contacts to message or call or documents.
You can even search directly into apps like Keynote, Messages, Mail or Files.
Or look up information about people or places.
And it's also a great place to start all of your web searches as well.
As soon as you start typing your relevant suggestions to complete your search.
And you can get to your web search results.
With just a tap.
And search now makes navigating to your favorite websites just as easy as launching an app.
Just type a few letters and the top hit will take you right to the start.
So those are some of our updates to the iPad experience.
And of course, you get the new widgets and all the other great app enhancements from iOS 14.
Next, we want to push forward your ability to express yourself creatively with improvements to Apple Pencil.
Apple Pencil is a game-changing tool that turns iPad into a professional drawing canvas.
Okay.
Can ich nichts zu sagen, nie verwendet.
And the ultimate note-taking device.
What many people love most about taking notes with Apple Pencil is how they can express themselves in a free-form way.
Mixing handwriting and drawings can be the best way to capture your thoughts.
Now, the challenge is when you want to change things afterwards.
Here, working with handwriting just isn't as easy as with typed text.
Now, we sometimes take it for granted.
But with typed text, it's so easy to select, copy and paste into another document, or even just make space for more text.
Well, this year, we're going to make handwriting just as easy and just as powerful.
But that's not all.
Our customers tell us that once they have an Apple Pencil in their hand, they don't want to put it away.
So this year, we're bringing Scribble to iPad.
So you can handwrite into any text field and it will automatically be converted to text.
To show you all of this in action, I'd like to welcome Jenny Cheng for a live demo.
Thanks, Ray. I'm really excited to show you some of the great new features that we have for Apple Pencil and iPad OS this year.
One of the great parts about taking notes with the Apple Pencil is that it really lets you work in a free-form way.
I can just start writing anywhere.
And it's not just about text.
I can also express myself with drawings or shapes.
But sometimes you want that more professional, cleaned-up look.
And so now, when I draw a simple shape and pause at the end, it will automatically convert to that ideal shape.
And we're smart about it, retaining the same size and angle that you drew it at.
In addition to shapes, we've also made huge improvements to our handwriting recognition.
So now, when I write, I can easily make a selection using the same gestures that I use for typed text.
I can double-tap to select a word.
Chat, man wird für alles irgendwo auf der Welt was finden, was das schon kann.
Da geht's aber jetzt ja nicht drum, oder?
Das sieht aus wie auf den Surfers unten.
Das sieht original aus wie auf den Surfershub unten.
Haben sie sich gut inspirieren lassen.
Let's say you wanna search for Edison bulbs and Safari.
Mit Scribble kann ich einfach direkt in das Textfeld schreiben und es wird automatisch konvertiert in Text.
Es funktioniert auch in jedem Textfeld.
Also kann ich einfach einen neuen Erinnerungskarton hinzufügen, zu meiner gemeinsamen Erinnerungskarte mit meinem Mann.
Ich habe auch Chinesisch gelernt, also möchte ich sie mit einigen meiner Prozesse und Fähigkeiten überraschen.
Ich benutze Scratch, um Licht zu erledigen.
Und dann kann ich Scribble benutzen, um Neues zu schreiben.
Und dann Lichtfixierung in Chinesisch.
Du wirst bemerken, wie Scribble sowohl Englisch als auch Chinesisch in der gleichen Linie erkennt.
Und das Tolle ist, dass wir mit dieser Technologie, um andere tolle Featuren zu erledigen, wie Datendetektoren.
Wir können automatisch das, was du schreibst, wie Telefonnummern, damit ich ein Telefonnummer machen kann, oder Adressen, damit ich Rechnungen suchen kann.
Wir können diese Features zusammen nutzen, um noch mehr mit deiner Handzeichen zu tun.
Sagen wir, ich wollte meine Handzeichen in einer anderen App verwenden.
Ich kann einfach das, was ich will, wählen.
Klick die neue Karte.
Kopiere als Text aus der Anzeige-Bar.
Und dann paste es in eine App wie Pages.
Und es wird automatisch zum Text-Typen konvertiert.
Wir sind wirklich gespannt auf diese tollen neuen Features.
Und wir denken, dass wir dir noch mehr mit der Apple-Technologie tun werden.
Danke, Jenny.
Also das sind die Verbesserungen zu Pencil.
Nur ein Teil einer großartigen Veröffentlichung.
Mit Scribble für Handzeichen in jedem Textfeld.
Ein ganz neuer Weg, mit deinen handwrittenen Noten zu arbeiten.
Große Handzeichen für die App-Erfahrung.
Und natürlich.
iPad-Händler werden auch von den tollen Featuren, die du bereits in iOS 14 gesehen hast,
und viel mehr, über die wir noch nicht Zeit hatten, sprechen können.
Also das sind iOS und iPadOS.
Nächstes Mal sprechen wir über AirPods.
Von dem Ein-Klick-Setup,
zum automatischen Paaren mit all deinen Geräten,
bis zu der Art, wie sie dein Audio pausieren, wenn du sie rausnimmst.
Die Leute lieben die magische Erfahrung, die AirPods anbieten.
Jetzt bringen wir noch mehr Magie zu AirPods.
Um dir alles darüber zu erzählen,
hier ist Marianne Ionoscu.
PURE MAGIE!
Bei AirPods ist es viel schwieriger, wenn du nur einen einzigen Handzeichen im Jahr hast.
Also hat unsere Team die advanced spatial audio Algorithmen für AirPods Pro entwickelt,
die die Movie Theater-Experienz replizieren.
Ah, ja.
Durch die Applikation von direktionalen Audiofiltern
und der subtilen Einrichtung der Frequenzen, die jedes Hände erhält,
können wir Geräte in fast jeder Stelle im Raum spielen,
um eine immersive Surround-Sound-Erfahrung zu schaffen.
Aber um diese Versicherung wirklich zu erzeugen,
mussten wir in echten Leben Situationen feststellen.
Zuerst müssen die Leute ihre Hände bewegen.
Für eine authentische Surround-Sound-Erfahrung
musst du das Soundfeld festhalten,
damit die Stimme aus dem Akteur kommt
und nicht aus einem randomen Punkt im Raum.
Wir nutzen also den Accelerometer,
Gyroskope und AirPods Pro,
um die Bewegung deines Händes zu bemerken.
Wir werden das Soundfeld wiederentwickeln,
damit es sich an deinem Gerät befindet,
auch wenn deine Hände sich bewegen.
Und es ist nicht nur deine Hände, die sich bewegen,
sondern auch dein iPad oder dein iPhone.
Das ist der Grund, warum wir ständig die Bewegungsdaten
deines Kopfes und deines Bildes vergleichen,
um zu verstehen, wie sie sich bewegen
in Beziehung zu einander.
Also, wenn dein Bus die Kante dreht
oder dein Flugzeug bankt,
bleibt der Sound in Sync.
Das Ergebnis ist eine Surround-Sound-Erfahrung,
die dich in der Mitte der Aktion hält,
egal wo du bist.
Spatial Audio für AirPods Pro
funktioniert mit Content-Encoded
in 5.1, 7.1 und sogar Dolby Atmos.
Danke, Marianne.
Ich benutze das neue Spatial-Audio,
und ich denke, ihr werdet es alle wirklich lieben.
Gut, dann gehen wir weiter
zum Fitness-Zentrum,
um das Neueste von WatchOS von Kevin zu hören.
Danke, Craig.
Seitdem wir Apple Watch geöffnet haben,
ist es komplett redefiniert, was eine Watch tun kann.
Und das hat unglaublich bedeutende Arbeit gemacht.
Apple Watch hilft dir nicht nur,
verbunden und aktiv zu bleiben,
sondern du wirst ein intelligenter Anwalt deiner Gesundheit werden,
die dir ermöglicht, ein ECG zu nehmen,
und dir Anrufe zu anrufen.
Das haben sie uns letztes Jahr erzählt, ja.
Die Kraft von Apple Watch ist nicht nur ihre verbauten Features,
sondern auch, wie die Anwälte es für dich personalisierten.
Letztes Jahr haben sie uns noch die Schwangere gezeigt,
wo Apple Watch den Krankenwagen gerufen hat oder sowas.
Könnt ihr euch auch daran erinnern?
Diese Apps bringen die Informationen,
über die du am meisten interessiert bist,
nur mit einem Blick auf deine Watch-Face.
Und wir nehmen das noch weiter in WatchOS 7.
Zuerst mit Komplikationen.
Bis heute könnte eine App nur auf einem Spot
der Zeit auf einer Watch-Face.
In WatchOS 7 können Entwickler
mehrere Komplikationen ermöglichen,
um noch mehr persönliche Watch-Faces zu erzeugen.
Wenn du also Dawn Patrol für Surfen nutzen möchtest,
kannst du deine eigene Surfen-Watch erstellen,
mit Wasser-Temperatur,
Schwell- und Wind-Speed-Prediktionen
für deine Lieblings-Beech.
Oder neue Eltern können Glow-Baby nutzen,
um zu sehen, wie Nap, Veränderungen und Fertigzeiten
alle auf der gleichen Phase sind.
Und Nike Run Club kann Stats zeigen,
wie die Zeit von deiner letzten Runde
Ich frag mich immer, wie die auf den ganzen Kram kommen.
Das sind alles so Sachen, wo ich mir denke,
okay, eigentlich brauchen wir es nicht,
aber es gibt doch Leute, die brauchen es.
Und eine neu gebildete extra große Face
mit einer riesigen Komplikation
direkt im Zentrum.
Und die Konfigurierung von Watch-Faces
hat einen neuen Design,
so dass du einfach wählen kannst,
welche Informationen du sehen möchtest.
Als Entwickler mit WatchOS 7
kannst du jetzt deine riesigen Komplikationen
mit der nativen Swift-UI erarbeiten.
Während es so viele Möglichkeiten gibt,
Watch-Faces zu konfigurieren,
kannst du sie vielleicht noch nicht
für dich selbst einstellen.
Das ist okay.
Mit WatchOS 7 machen wir es super einfach,
Watch-Faces zu teilen.
So kannst du eine Face entdecken,
die für dich perfekt funktioniert.
Um das zu tun,
werden wir die Face-Teilung vorstellen.
Was?
Du wirst die gebildeten Faces entdecken
mit dritten Teil-Apps auf der App-Store.
Oder entdecken einen neuen Lieblings-Watch-Face
direkt auf einem Website.
Oder bekommst Watch-Faces direkt
von Freunden und Familie.
Schauen wir uns das an, wie das funktioniert.
Wenn du eine Watch-Face sehen möchtest,
drückst du einfach an,
add Apple Watch-Face.
Wenn die Watch-Face...
Ach, das...
Ist das...
Die Desktop-Anordnung ist da...
Ah.
Watch-Face ist quasi ein neues Wort
für Layout.
Fast immer.
Diese Anordnung kann man mit
einfachen Speicher-Methoden
durch den desktop-Face Ezahn
des iPhone auswählen.
Speicher-Map-Face ist wichtig
für das Gehen und Fahren
und die Fahrtzeiten.
Und jetzt kann man in Watch OS
genauso wie in iOS 14
Fahrzeuge finden.
Du siehst verschiedene Routen
mit Informationen wie Zeit,
Distanz
und ob es Fahrräder gibt.
Man kann den Zugang
oder die Bremse
auswählen
und mit turn-by-turn-Führungen
aufwachsen,
die groß sind
und einfach zu lesen sind.
Timemengen
Mapps können Sie direkt ausbauen und Ihren Fahrrad fahren oder sogar die Stiefel nehmen, um Zeit zu sparen.
Sie können auch eine App suchen, die für Fahrradfahrer optimiert ist, wie Fahrrad-Repair-Shops.
Das kostet eine Apple Watch eigentlich.
Bitte willkommen, Jules Arne.
Danke, Kevin.
Die Workout-App verwendet Algorithmen, die auf alle Aspekte Ihres Trainings angepasst werden.
Es ist eine der am meisten genannten Apps auf der Apple Watch.
Und wir haben jedes Jahr neue Workout-Typen unterstützt.
Und bei der WatchOS 7 werden wir Dance hinzufügen.
Dance ist ein totaler Body-Workout, das Sie für Ihr Herz bringt.
Es macht Sie fitter und flexibler und garantiert, dass Sie Spaß haben.
Ob Sie Hip-Hop, Latein, Bollywood oder einfach Cardio-Dance machen.
Die Workout-App trackt jetzt nur die populären Stile der Dance für Fitness.
Behandeln Sie einen Charakter, in dem der Dance eine unheimliche Herausforderung ist.
Unsere Bewegungen sind nicht immer wiederholbar.
Oder synchronisierte Beine-Bewegungen, wie beim Laufen und Runnen.
Die Lösung war, mit der Advanced-Fixierung...
Nein, der Counter ist kaputt.
In der Dance kombinieren wir Daten aus dem Accelerometer und dem Gyroskop,
um die Unterschiede zwischen dem Tanzen mit nur Ihren Armen,
mit nur Ihrem unteren Körper
oder wenn Sie es zusammenfügen und mit Ihrem gesamten Körper tanzen.
Dann sind wir in Heart-Rate-Daten für die bestmögliche Calorie-Burn-Kalkulation.
Die WatchOS 7 trackt auch die bestmöglichen Kalorien für das Core-Training.
Diese Übungen für Ihre Abs und Beine.
Funktionales Strength-Training,
ein Workout-Type, das Sie stärker und besser für tägliche Aktivitäten bewegen kann.
Und auch Cooldowns.
Um ein weiteres Workout hinzuzufügen,
wenn Sie mit einfachen Bewegungen und Streckungen weitergehen wollen,
als Sie das Heart-Rate-Training wieder normal zurückbringen.
Natürlich, Sie können den Fortschritt für diese neuen Workouts
innerhalb der Aktivitäts-App auf iPhone,
die komplett wiederentwickelt ist in der WatchOS 7.
Die App bietet jetzt eine neue Summary-Tab,
die Ihnen einen einfachen Weg gibt,
Ihre Aktivitätsgeschichte, Workouts und Trends zu sehen.
Alle in einem sinnvollen Blick.
Mit einem neuen Fokus auf einfaches Navigieren und Summary-Metriken
bekommt die App einen neuen Namen.
Fitness.
Zurück zu Ihnen, Kevin.
Danke, Jules.
Bitte.
Apple Watch hilft Ihnen, nicht nur Ihre Fitness-Gehälter zu erreichen,
sondern auch Ihre Gesundheit zu unterstützen.
Mit Features wie Cycle-Tracking,
der Breathe-App und Geräusch-Notifikationen.
Und wir werden dieses Jahr noch mehr Fähigkeiten in WatchOS 7 hinzufügen.
Wir möchten heute ein paar davon mit Ihnen teilen.
Zuerst mit einem der wichtigsten,
die Apple Watch vorliegt.
Tracking Ihren Schlaf.
Um Ihnen darüber zu erzählen,
gehen Sie zu Vera Carr.
Danke, Kevin.
Es gibt viele Möglichkeiten,
Schlaf zu betrachten.
Scores,
Advanced Monitoring
oder Schlafzyklen-Analysen.
Wir nehmen einen holistischeren Ansatz zum Schlaf,
indem wir die Geräte, die Sie jeden Tag benutzen,
nutzen,
um nicht nur Ihren Schlaf zu tracken,
sondern auch, um Sie zu unterstützen,
Ihren Schlaf-Duration-Gehalt zu erreichen.
Das beginnt mit der Wahl,
nicht nur, wenn Sie sich am Morgen wachen möchten,
sondern auch, wenn Sie sich schlafen möchten.
Für die meisten von uns ist es einfach,
ein Ziel zu setzen,
aber das Schwierigste ist,
sich auf Zeit zu schlafen.
Experten sagen,
dass die Erstellung einer Schlafzeit-Routine
den Körper helfen kann,
von Wachsamkeit
zum Schlafen.
Also, wir eröffnen das Schlafzimmer.
Es kann Ihnen helfen,
sich auf Zeit zu schlafen,
indem Sie sich unverlustig
und eine persönliche Routine entwickeln.
Schauen wir uns das an, wie das funktioniert.
Am Abend vor Ihrem Schlafzeit-Routine
kann Ihr Smartphone das Schlafzimmer anzeigen,
um Sie,
bevor Sie schlafen gehen,
mental zu verändern.
Es erzeugt eine ruhige Schlafzimmer-Erfahrung
und schaltet auf
Do Not Disturb für Sie ein.
Sie können auch Shortcuts einstellen,
für einfache Dinge,
die Sie machen möchten,
um Sie für das Schlafzimmer zu vorbereiten.
Diese können Sie mit Ihrem Lieblings-Meditation-App
oder mit der Musik spielen.
Sobald es Zeit für das Schlafzimmer ist,
wird Ihr Schlafzimmer dünn,
und Ihr Schlafzimmer wird ins Schlafmodus gehen.
Das sieht so aus.
Das Schlafzimmer wird während des Schlafzimmers aus,
also wird es Sie nicht interessieren,
und ein Tapp zeigt diese einfache Gesichter.
Wenn es Zeit ist, sich aufzuwachen,
haben Sie eine Auswahl von leisen und effektiven Alarmmuskeln
oder eine leise, taptische Aufwärts-Alarm,
damit Sie Ihre Uhr nicht zerstören.
Sobald Sie aufwachen,
sehen Sie ein freundliches Gebet,
das Sie in den Tag einführt.
Es zeigt auch Ihr Batterielevel,
damit Sie sich erinnern,
am Morgen zu schlafen.
Apple Watch trackt Ihren Schlaf
mit einem Maschinen-Lernmodell,
der Ihre Bewegung spürt
und sogar die Mikromovements interpretiert,
die durch den Aufstieg und den Fall Ihres Atems
durchgeführt werden.
Sie bietet Signale für,
wann Sie wach sind und wann Sie schlafen.
Es gibt eine neu gebildete Schlafseite in der Health App,
die eine Ausgabe Ihrer Trends über die Zeit enthält.
Schlafschedule, Wind-Down und Schlafmodus
sind auch auf dem iPhone und iOS 14
mit Autowatch verfügbar.
Wir wissen, dass Sie Ihren Autowatch
über den Tag und die Nacht genießen werden.
Vielen Dank, Vera.
In Bezug auf das Schlafen,
was Sie gesund machen,
gibt es noch ein weiteres
vorwärtshaltendes Wachstum,
das so wichtig ist,
besonders jetzt.
Handwaschen.
In WatchOS 7 ist Apple Watch
der erste Wachstum,
der die automatische Betrachtung erhält,
wenn Sie Ihre Hände starten
und merken, wie lange Sie wirklich waschen.
Unsere Anwendung hier ist,
Maschinen-Lernmodelle zu nutzen,
um die Bewegung zu bestätigen,
wie schnell Sie Ihre Hand waschen
und dann Audio zu nutzen,
um den Geräusch des fliegenden Wassers
oder von Ihren Händen zu spüren.
Maschinen-Lernmodelle.
Während des Wachstums
bekommen Sie ein wenig Trainings,
um einen guten Job zu machen.
Sie werden ein Konto sehen,
zusammen mit Haptiken und Geräuschen,
um sicherzustellen,
dass Sie so lange waschen,
wie Sie sollen.
Wenn Sie früh aufhören,
gibt es eine leichte Note,
um weiter zu waschen.
Und wenn Sie fertig sind,
werden Sie sehen, hören und fühlen.
Das ist nur ein Teil
dessen, was dieses Jahr kommt
in WatchOS 7,
insbesondere das Erkennen
und das Teilen von Füßen,
neue Workout-Typen,
Schlaf- und Handwaschen-Detektion
und andere neue Fähigkeiten,
wie Siri-Language-Vertrag.
Und das ist Apple Watch.
Es ist Zeit,
dass wir wieder mit Craig zusammen sind,
um über etwas zu sprechen,
das für uns alle wichtig ist.
Los geht's!
Handwaschen-Detektion.
Okay, also,
das ist du echt schon
ein bisschen weit hergeholt.
Oh, Privacy.
By the way, das ist das Gebäude,
wo die Leute gegen die Glastüren
rennen teilweise.
Müssen wir suchen danach.
Privacy zählt jetzt
mehr als jemals.
Und weil unsere Geräte
so viel Informationen haben,
ist unser Produktwerk
aufgrund einer Art
von Privatsprinzipien gegründet.
Zuerst,
Minimierung von Daten.
Wir nutzen innovativen Technologien
und Techniken,
um die persönlichen Daten zu minimieren,
die wir oder jeder andere
accessieren kann.
Zweitens,
Auf-Device-Intelligenz.
Wir verhindern,
Daten zu sammeln,
indem wir so viel
von eurer Information
auf eurer Geräte
wie wir können,
anstatt sie zu einem Server zu senden.
Drittens,
Sicherheit.
Sicherheits-Verteidigungen
sind die Grundlage
für alles,
was wir in der Privatsprinzipie tun.
Und letztens,
Transparenz und Kontrolle.
Sie helfen Ihnen,
die Daten besser zu verstehen,
so dass Sie
Ihre eigenen Entscheidungen
darüber machen können,
wie diese Daten genutzt werden.
Diese Prinzipien
kommen zusammen
in unseren Produkten,
in unseren Hardwaren,
in unseren Softwaren
und in unseren Services.
Am Ende des Tages
resultieren sie
in großartiger Privatsprinzip
und in großartiger Anwendung.
Ein starkes Beispiel
davon ist
Sign-In mit Apple,
das für Simplifität,
Sicherheit
und Privatsprinzip
geschaffen wurde.
Und seitdem wir
es letztes Jahr
geöffnet haben,
haben die Anwender
über 200 Millionen
Anwender
über eine große
Vielfalt
von Apps
und Webseiten
gegründet.
Und die Anwender
sehen großartige Anwendungen
für das,
was sie anbieten.
Zum Beispiel
hat Kayak
mit Apple
gegründet,
und sie haben
ihre Anwender
nun zweimal
besser
als andere
Sign-In Anwender.
Nun,
eine Sache,
die wir oft hören
mit Sign-In mit Apple,
ist,
dass wir
es in diesem Jahr
den Entwicklern
ermöglichen,
dass sie
genau das machen.
Wenn sie sich
verbessern,
bekommen sie
die Einführung
und die
Sicherheitsmöglichkeit
für das Sign-In mit Apple
während sie
das Account
schon haben.
Das ist
ein weiteres
großes Jahr
für
unsere
Produkte.
Und um
mehr zu
erzählen,
hier sind
Katie Skinner
und Eric Neuenschwander.
Danke, Craig.
Vielen Dank,
dass ihr
mit uns
hier
gesprochen
habt.
Wir haben
auch
Ähnliches
für
die
App-Version
für
die
App-Version
und die
für
die
App-Version.
Wir
werden auch
Ähnliches
für
die
App-Version
für
die
App-Version
machen.
Das heißt,
die App-Version
sollte immer
transparent
und unter
eurer Kontrolle
sein.
Also,
weiter
vorwärts,
App-Store-Policy
wird
App-Apps
fragen,
bevor sie
über Apps und
Websites
von anderen
Firmen
tracken.
Ja, das geht bei Android
nicht, wenn du
Bluetooth anmachst.
Wird alles
geshared.
Wouldn't it be great
even more quickly
with sugar
or maybe
both
all before
you buy
it?
So we
thought it
would be
great to
have something
similar
for
apps.
We're
going to
require
each
developer
to
self-report
their
practices.
We'll
show
you
what
they
tell
you
when
you download
it.
And we're
going to
explain this
in all our
answers.
Back over
to you, Craig.
Thanks, Katie
and Eric.
These are some
of the ways
we're strengthening
the privacy
of our
platforms and
bringing new
features to
give users
even more
control.
And one of the
places where
privacy matters
most is
your home.
And that brings
us to some
great new
features we're
bringing to the
home this
year.
All of these
features share a
few key
attributes.
First,
anything we
develop for
the home
should be
easy,
from initial
setup to
everyday
use,
just like
how a
tap of
your
iPhone
can
automatically
configure
an
iPhone.
Like how Airplay
lets you share
from your iPhone
straight to the
TV.
And when things
are easy,
private and
work together
seamlessly,
your home is
more enjoyable.
Whether you're
watching TV,
listening to
music or
getting the
most out of
your smart
devices.
To tell you
more about
what we
have in
store for
the home,
let me pass
it to
you.
We have
an
incredibly easy
to set
up,
all while being
end-to-end
encrypted to
your Apple
devices.
Already,
there's a rich
ecosystem of
devices available.
But we want to
make it even
easier to
build products
that work
across more
homes.
So,
we've
opened an
alliance
and partnered
with Amazon
and other
companies to
create a
smart home
kit.
This new
standard will
work incredibly
well across
all your
Apple devices.
Mario noch
nix.
The most
secure way
to manage
your smart
home.
Adding new
devices to
your home
has never
been easier.
Simply tap
or scan
to set
up an
accessory.
And in
iOS 14,
you can
see the
torch lights
when motion
is detected
or having
the garage
door open
as you arrive
home.
And now,
when you
open the
home app,
you see a
new visual
status right
up top
that prioritizes
the accessories
which most
need your
attention.
You can
easily see
if you've
left the
door
unlocked
or the
lights
on.
You also
have the
feature to
help you
get the
most out
of those
bulbs.
Adaptive lighting.
Adaptive lighting
automatically
adjusts
the color
temperature
of your
lights
throughout
the day.
Turn it
on to ease
into the
morning
with warm
colors.
Stay focused
and alert
midday
to make
your cameras
work even
harder.
You'll be able
to define
activity zones
that focus
on the most
important areas.
This is great
if you face
a busy
sidewalk
and only
want to be
alerted
when people
actually walk
up to your
front door.
Another powerful
feature we're
bringing to
cameras is
face recognition.
HomeKit
cameras and
video doorbells
extend to
home
problems
and help
people
who
lose
at the
door.
And with
Apple TV,
you get a
live
view
whenever
someone
rings
the
bell.
In fact,
all the
HomeKit
enabled
cameras
will be
directly
integrated
with
tvOS 14.
Now let me
pass it to
Cindy Lynn
to tell you
about it.
Thanks,
yeah.
Apple TV is
my favorite way
to unwind
and enjoy
entertainment
with the family.
With 4K,
HDR,
Dolby Vision
and Dolby Atmos
right in your
living room,
making all
your movies
and shows
look and
sound amazing.
But Apple TV
goes beyond video.
You can access
the entire
Apple Music
Networks.
You can play
an incredible
selection
of games.
It looks
like Animal Crossing
plus it's
schlecht.
And we're
making gaming
on Apple TV
even more
personal
by expanding
multi-user
support.
Now you can
instantly
resume
your games
exactly
where you
left off.
Just open
Control Center
to switch
between users
and you can
play
your own
games.
Apple TV
also helps
you keep
active at home
with a great
selection of
fitness apps.
And with TVOS 14
we're gonna make
your workouts
and everything
you do on
Apple TV
even more
productive
by extending
picture in
picture across
the entire
Apple TV
experience.
So you can
keep up with
the news
or not miss
a second
on iPhone
in their full
4K resolution.
With videos,
music,
games and
more,
Apple TV
truly offers
something for
everyone.
Of course,
nothing compares
to being
captivated
by a good
story.
And we've
built a service
for just that.
Apple TV
Plus.
We've already
created an
incredible
lineup of
Apple Originals.
And you can
watch them all
with the
best content
and many
popular
Smart TVs.
Ready reaching
over a billion
screens.
And it's coming
to Sony and
Vizio's
Smart TVs
later this
summer.
Today,
we're really
excited to tell
you about a
new Apple TV
Plus Original
that we're
working on.
Almost 70
years ago,
Isaac Asimov
introduced the world
TV series
of all time.
I'd like to share
a sneak peek
with you now.
This is
Foundation.
You're going
to arrest me
tomorrow.
And you.
It's almost
a certainty.
You're familiar
with my work,
Psychohistory?
Yes.
In theory,
but I don't know
what it has to do.
It's not a theory.
I'm worried
you can predict
the future.
Can an Asimov
have a
piecekin?
I'm worried
people believe
I can,
and they don't
like the future
I predict.
The Empire
will fall.
Order
will vanish.
There's
massive
events
rushing
to meet
us.
Only
we
can
shorten
the
darkness.
Okay.
I'm super
excited to
watch
what happens
to us
next year.
With Apple TV,
your home
has never
been more
entertaining.
And with adaptive
lighting,
face recognition
for cameras
and these other
great features,
your time at home
has never
been more
enjoyable.
Now let me
hand it back
to Craig.
Okay.
Gut.
Ich werde
definitiv
noch ein Abo
holen.
Welcome back.
Now let's talk
about the MacOS.
The MacOS
revolutionized
the experience
of using
a computer
by combining
incredible power
with incredible
ease of use.
And it's loved
by all different
types of users,
from families
and students
to creative
pros,
business people
and of course
software developers.
And this year
we're taking
the MacOS
experience
you love
even further.
But what
should we
call it?
A track marketing team.
Their drug-fueled
mini-bus driven
vision quests
have yielded
some great names
and sadly
spawned a host
of imitators.
The truth is
we can't responsibly
continue to inadvertently
lead our competition
to copy these methods
when they clearly
can't handle the trip.
So this year
we're leaving our process
shrouded in mystery
and taking you straight
to the glorious
destination.
Our next release
of MacOS
is MacOS
Big Sur.
Big
Sur.
introduces
highly new design
and major updates
to some of the most
essential apps
on the platform.
And just like its name,
Big Sur brings you
unmatched levels
of power
and beauty.
Let's start with
design.
Okay, Big Sur
is
the biggest change
since the introduction
of MacOS 10.
I'll tell you more
about the philosophy
and incredible craftsmanship
behind the new design.
Here's a short video
with Alan Dye.
At Apple,
design has always been
about great ideas.
Those ideas then
are developed
with this
obsessive dedication
Einhorn
deselbst feiern.
If we care enough
about all the details
that make up a product,
then in the end
we will design
an experience
that really feels
like there's no other way
it could be.
And the best example
of this
is MacOS
Big Sur.
Our goal
was to bring
even more clarity
to the design
of the software
while retaining
the Mac's
powerful capability
and ease of use.
We started
with the simplest
of elements
from the shape
of a corner radius
to refinements
and buttons
and controls.
And we brought
our unified language
of symbols
to the Mac
making them
more consistent
and easier
to recognize.
Depth,
shading
and translucency
are used
to create hierarchy.
These new materials
are rich
and they're vibrant.
They bridge
light
and dark.
We've reduced
visual complexity
to keep the focus
of the system
in the right place.
Buttons and controls
appear when you need them
and they recede
when you don't.
There's a new way
to access
system-level controls
and a unified space
for notifications
and widgets.
It looks
more and more
like iOS.
They're familiar
to the Mac
but remastered
and more refined.
We wanted
consistency
throughout the ecosystem
so users
can move fluidly
between their
Apple devices.
We also love
that Mac icons
have a deep history
and a distinct
look and feel.
So we retain
many of the highly
crafted details
and the playful elements
that make Mac icons
unique.
This OS reflects
an important history.
It's familiar
but it's also
entirely new
in every detail.
We love the Mac.
It's the tool
we use to make
all the products
that we put out
into the world.
And Mac OS Big Sur
is where it starts.
So that's the thinking
behind our new design.
Now let me show it
to you in action
with a demo.
As Alan said,
we've refined
some of the most
iconic elements
of the Mac experience.
Let's start
with the dock.
It has an elegant
new design
that floats
along the bottom
of your desktop.
And you'll notice
that we've created
gorgeous new app icons
for all of your
favorite apps.
Speaking of apps,
let's take a look
at the finder.
It has gorgeous
and top-to-bottom design
for the sidebar.
And it has a compact,
space-efficient toolbar.
Makes it really easy
to get to all
of your controls.
Next,
let's take a look
at mail.
You can see
that mail has
all new glyphs
in the sidebar.
And you may be able
to see
a lot of color back
as well.
Now each app
uses its own key color.
And that same color
is used
for the elegant
new rounded
row selection style
here in the message list.
Now the toolbar
makes it really easy
to get to all
of your controls.
Check out how
the search bar
expands as I click
on it.
And of course,
other operations
like filtering,
well,
they're just a click away.
Next,
let's take a look
at photos.
It's just stunning.
You can get to
all of your albums
and media types
from the sidebar.
And the photo grid
is backed by metal.
So animations
are super smooth,
whether I'm scrolling,
transitioning,
or zooming
all the way in
or all the way out.
Beautiful.
So,
now,
we've refreshed
the design
for all the apps
in the system.
From apps like
Calendar and Notes
to Podcasts
and Music
with its new
Listen Now pane
and an all-new
version of iWork
that features
a simplified
toolbar.
Sag mal,
wenn du dem zuhörst,
ist alles
nicht einfach
nur new,
sondern all new.
Als hätten sie alles
laufend
neu programmiert.
Das ist doch Blödsinn.
And we've updated
the layout
of menus
in the Mac.
Now,
on the Mac,
we love our ability
to get directly at controls,
like Wi-Fi
or sound.
And you can see
that we've reworked
these to be
even more useful.
But we've gone
even further this year
by giving you
one place
to get all your
intents.
We've brought
Control Center
to the Mac.
Oh,
das wird
kontroversen,
kontroversen geben.
For instance,
I could change
display brightness
here
und das habe
ich euch.
Die meisten Mac-User
haben nämlich überhaupt
keinen Bock
auf iOS
auf dem Desktop.
So,
say I want
one-click access
to do not disturb.
Well,
I can just click
and drag it
right into my menu bar
and customize
just like that.
Now,
we've also reinvented
Notification Center.
You can access it
by clicking on the time
in the upper right.
And as you see,
we now have
a single view
that brings
your notifications
and widgets together
and we now group
related notifications
together.
You can easily
expand them
to take a closer look
or clear them
all out
in one step.
And we're bringing
our redesigned widgets
to the Mac.
They're really beautiful
and you have
all new ways
to customize them.
I'm just gonna click
Edit Widgets
down here at the bottom
and you can see
I have a gallery
of all my widgets
and they come
in a variety
of sizes
just like this.
And developers
can bring
their own widgets
as well,
like this one here
from day one.
Now, adding widgets
is easy.
Let's start
by adding, say,
the world clock.
Maybe I'll add
notes in.
It would be kinda cool
to add my
reminders list
as well.
So that's a look
at Widgets,
Notification Center
and our all new
design in Big Sur.
Next,
there are exciting updates
for some of the most
new tabs
on the Mac.
First,
let's talk about
Messages.
Messages on the Mac
is designed
to work seamlessly
with all of your devices.
So your SMS
and iMessage
conversations
are in sync
no matter what device
you're using.
Now this year,
we're taking
Messages to the next level
with a ton
of great new features.
We're introducing
powerful Search
to help you find
what you're looking for.
We have a redesigned
Photo Picker
to make sharing
photos and videos
easier.
And Memoji.
You can now create
and edit your Memoji
right on your Mac
and Memoji stickers
in your own way.
And you're also
getting pin conversations
that are synced
across devices
that you can
always get to them.
Along with new
groups enhancements.
So that's what's
coming to Messages
on Mac.
Powerful Tools
to manage
your conversations
and new ways
to express yourself.
Next up,
Maps.
Apple Maps
is the best
way to manage
your conversations
and new ways
to express yourself.
Next up,
Maps.
Apple Maps
is the best
way to explore
and navigate
the world.
Whether you're planning
a trip on the Mac
or using
turn-by-turn directions
on your iPhone.
Today,
I'm excited
to announce
an all-new version
of Maps
for the Mac.
To start,
Maps features
a stunning new design
that makes it easy
to find your way around
using Apple's
detailed new map.
And for the first time
on the Mac,
favorites
like home,
work
or that great coffee shop
on the corner
are now just
available on the Mac.
All the places
you want to visit
right on your Mac.
All new Maps.
And before leaving
for the airport,
you can check
where your gate is located
with any more maps
or explore
your destination city
with Lookaround,
which is incredible
on the big screen.
We've even brought
other useful features
to the Mac.
We give you
the ability
to see the progress
of friends
who've shared
their ETA with you.
And the Mac gets
all the other
new Maps features
we just introduced
in iOS 14.
All new Apple Maps.
Next,
let's talk about
Mac Catalyst.
Catalyst gives developers
a big head start
in creating a Mac app
from an iPad app.
Take for instance
our recent release
of Swift Playgrounds
for Mac.
Catalyst gave us
a big head start
creating the app
and we were able
to spend our development time
crafting a great
Mac experience.
Today,
we have some improvements
to Mac Catalyst
I'd like to share.
This year,
developers will be able
to optimize their apps
and fully utilize
the native resolution
of the Mac screen
providing total control
of every pixel.
We've also given
developers new capabilities
including powerful
new menu
and keyboard APIs
and updated controls
like check boxes
and date pickers.
They look great
with the new design
of Mac OS.
In fact,
we use Catalyst
with the new
version of Maps.
And just as you'd expect,
it's a full-fledged
Mac app
that runs natively
and is designed
in a way that's true
to the Mac.
So you get multiple
resizable windows
and keyboard shortcuts
and everything else
you'd expect
from a native Mac app.
And we did the same
thing for Messages.
Maps and Messages
join the great set
of apps from Apple
that already use
the Mac Catalyst
technology.
And there's a growing
list of third-party
Catalyst apps
available on the
Mac App Store.
Next,
Safari.
Our users
love Safari
for its speedy
performance,
power efficiency
and state-of-the-art
privacy protections.
And it delivers
all of that
while making it easy
to get to your
bookmarks, tabs
and browsing history
across all of your devices.
This year,
we're building on
Safari's amazing
performance,
elegant design
and pioneering
privacy protections
to deliver the biggest
update to Safari
since it was
first introduced.
As you know,
Safari has long
been the world's
fastest
desktop browser.
Nein.
This year,
Safari's performance
running JavaScript
is better than ever
and continues
to significantly outpace
other major browsers.
And now,
when it comes to
page loading,
we're even faster
there, too.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
In fact,
when loading frequently
visited websites,
Safari is now on average
more than 50%
faster than Chrome.
And Safari delivers
this amazing
performance
while continuing
to deliver
industry-leading
battery life.
And of course,
Safari is continuing
to build on its
pioneering track record
protecting user privacy.
Safari was
the first browser
to introduce
browser browsing,
cookie blocking
and, most recently,
intelligent tracking
prevention.
This year,
we want to give our users
even more visibility
into how each site
they visit
tries to track them
and the ways
that Safari protects them.
So now users
can click on the
privacy report button
in the toolbar
when they visit a site
to better understand
how that site
is treating their privacy.
Okay, das ist cool.
Das ist ein bisschen
wie U-Block,
eingebaute U-Block.
Safari also securely
monitors your saved passwords
to ensure that
they haven't been compromised
in a data breach.
Das hat man in Bitwarden
letztens auch.
Das ist ganz nützlich.
We're adding support
for the Web Extensions API
so developers can easily
bring over extensions
that they built
for other browsers.
Das ist tatsächlich endlich.
Endlich.
And we're building an all-new
category in the Mac App Store
to showcase Safari Extensions
so users can easily find them.
Endlich.
Extensions are very powerful
but can introduce
privacy challenges.
In other browsers,
extensions can access
every page you visit,
every tab,
every tab you open,
even everything you type.
So we're doing
even more here.
In Safari,
you choose
which sites
each extension
can work with.
And you can even
give access
just for the day,
just for the website
or all the time.
But improved performance,
power efficiency
and privacy protections
are only the start.
We have a whole slew
of new features this year.
From a customizable
start page
to redesigned tabs
that are more elegant
and powerful
and native translation
capabilities
built right into Safari.
Also,
to tell you more
on hand,
Safari holt
nach 5 Jahren
hintendran
mal ein bisschen auf.
... to give you a tour
of the brand new Safari.
When you open Safari,
right away,
you'll notice
the new look.
It's clean
and fresh.
So I want to show you
one of my favorite
new features,
the customizable start page.
I love it
because I can make it my own.
It's easy to get
to the customization controls
here in the bottom corner.
I think a lot of people
are going to want
to set a background image.
And there's a beautiful gallery
of curatable papers
to choose from.
You can use
one of your own photos, too.
And I know
I want a photo of my son.
I have a few really cute ones
here in the downloads.
I can just drag
and drop to set it.
That is so perfect.
You can add new sections
to the start page, too.
Let's add iCloud tabs
and reading list.
Let's take a look.
Yeah,
this is perfect.
I use reading list
all the time.
Also,
you can add
new sections
to the start page, too.
Let's add iCloud tabs
and reading list.
I use reading list
all the time
and now it's so easy
to get to.
Another way
that you can dial in Safari
to suit your specific needs
is with extensions.
I can't wait
for you developers
to bring your web extensions
to Safari.
I've gone ahead
and downloaded
a few web extensions
to take a peek.
So let's go here
to the Safari preferences
to enable them.
And I'll enable
Power Thesaurus
and Recipe Filter.
So each of the extensions
that I just enabled
now has its own button
here in the toolbar.
Let me show you
Recipe Filter.
I love this.
So this extension
will search
the web page
for a recipe
and if it finds one
it will pop it up
in a little card.
It's been a great accelerator
for me
when I'm building
a grocery list.
So the extension
hasn't done anything yet
because I haven't
granted permission.
So let me click
on the toolbar button
and I'm going to
allow this extension
for one day
and when I click here
it'll do its thing.
So here we go.
And there it is.
So useful.
Okay, so I have
my personality
pretty thoroughly
stamped over Safari
at this point.
I use Safari
for a lot of
personal things
and Apple makes sure
my private life
stays private.
Privacy is essential
to everything we do
in Apple
and it's critical
on the web.
So now you can see
what Safari is doing
to get to you.
If I click on the
intelligent tracking
prevention button
I can see the number
of known trackers
that Safari protected
me from
on this web page.
I can click here
to see a list
of the known trackers
right here
in this popover
and the full list
of your products
is one per day.
So you can see
the privacy
in the new Safari.
Next I'd like to talk
about tabs.
If you love tabs
you're going to love
the new Safari.
It's easier
and more efficient
than ever
to work with lots of tabs.
So I have another window
here
and right away
you notice
that there are icons
and tabs
which makes it so easy
to spot what you're
looking for.
And if I open
more tabs
then you'll see
more of them at once
because the tabs
get smaller
and use the space
more efficiently.
If it's a little hard
to find any tabs
that's no problem.
You can just hover
over tabs
and see a nice
preview of the page.
I'm ready to clean up now
and that's easy too.
I can just bring up
the context menu here
and close all tabs
to the right.
Just like that.
We are so excited
that the new Safari
has built a translation.
Let me show you.
So here on this website
on El Mundo
Safari has detected
that this is not
my primary language
and it's added
the translation icon
to the search fields.
Okay, also ohne Scheiß
daran sieht man
dass es nicht
hinten dran Safari war.
Das sind Features
guckst du mal in Chrome
und guckst du Firefox
haben die teilweise
schon seit 5 Jahren.
Aber Safari ist auch
nach wie vor
das
eines der
größten Schwachstellen
unter iOS.
Was da teilweise
unterstützt wird
ist Jahre alt.
Guckt euch die PWA
Unterstützung an
wie hinten dran
die unter iOS war
und teilweise noch ist.
Und das Mac OS Big Sur.
Big Sur Alter,
da komme ich
auf den Namen klar.
Significant Updates
to Messages and Maps
and the biggest update
to Safari ever.
Aber diese Changes
are only the beginning.
For years now,
down deep below the surface,
we've been working
on something
truly profound.
Oh.
To tell you more,
I'll hand it back to Tim.
Jetzt kommt's.
Thanks Craig.
Armt CPUs.
Big Sur is going to be
a great release
of Mac OS Big Sur.
Big Sur ist
going to be
a great release
of Mac OS.
But that's only part
of the story.
Because today is going
to be a truly historic
day for the Mac.
Today we're going
to tell you about
some really big changes.
How we're going
to take the Mac
to a whole new level.
From the very beginning,
the Mac redefined
the entire
computer industry.
The Mac has always
been about innovation
and boldly pushing
things forward.
Embracing big changes
to stay at the forefront
of personal computing.
The Mac has had
three major changes
in the last few years.
One of them
has been
that the Mac
has had three major
transitions in its history.
The move to PowerPC.
The transition to Mac OS X.
And the move to Intel.
And now it's time
for a huge leap forward
for the Mac.
Because today
is the day
we're announcing
that the Mac
is transitioning
to rise
to our own
Apple Silicon.
When we make bold changes,
it's for one simple
yet powerful reason.
So we can make
new products.
When we look ahead,
we envision
some amazing new products
and transitioning
to our own
custom silicon
is what will enable
us to bring them to life.
At Apple,
integrating hardware
and software
is fundamental
to everything we do.
That's what makes
our products so great.
And silicon
is at the heart
of our hardware.
So having
a world-class
silicon design team
is a game changer.
To tell you more
about Apple Silicon
and how it will take
Mac to the next level,
I'd like to send you over
to Johnny Cerugy
at one of our labs
in an undisclosed location.
Welcome to our lab.
We've been building
and refining
our Apple Silicon
for over a decade.
The result
is a scalable architecture
that is custom designed
for Apple products
and it leads
the industry
in features
to performance
per watt.
So I'd love
to tell you
how we got here
and what it means
for the Mac moving forward.
It all started
with the iPhone.
The iPhone demanded
performance and capabilities
that were seen
as impossible
in a device that small.
This is where
we developed
our relentless focus
on performance per watt.
Generation after generation
we put the power
into technology
which enabled us
to improve performance
and energy efficiency
while building advanced
and industry-leading features.
Our team
delivered ten generations
of increasingly
complex and rich designs,
always improving performance.
In fact,
CPU performance
in the iPhone
has improved
by over a hundred times,
keeping the iPhone's
performance ahead
of every other phone
in the industry.
Another opportunity
for the team
was the iPad.
While iPhone chips
could drive
our mainstream iPads,
we wanted to push
the iPad even further.
It began
with the iPad's
Retina display
which demanded
a custom chip.
So the team
scaled our architecture
and designed
the most optimized
and highest performance
chip possible
for the iPad.
Starting with the A5X,
we built a line
of SoCs
specifically designed
for the iPad.
We doubled
the iPhone's
graphics performance
through a larger GPU
and a wider
memory subsystem.
This put the iPad
in a class by itself.
Compared to
the very first iPad,
the latest iPad Pro
delivers over
one thousand times
faster graphics
performance
in just ten years.
This is part
of the reason
why the iPad Pro
is faster
than the vast majority
of PC laptops.
And this
foreshadows
how well
our architecture
will scale
into the Mac.
Another place
where we applied
our focus
was the watch.
We scaled
our SoC architecture
to optimize
performance
for the device's
unique low-power
requirements.
And we built
a chip perfectly
suited
for Apple Watch.
Our SoCs
enable each
of these products
with unique features
and industry-leading
performance per watt.
And it makes
each of them
even more
powerful.
In fact,
adding all of the
processors across
these three products,
we've shipped
over two billion
in just ten years.
And we've designed
and shipped billions
of additional chips
that work together
with our SoCs
to enable
our amazing products.
And now we're bringing
all of that expertise
and that same
focused
and disciplined
approach
to the Mac.
The first thing
this will do
is give the Mac
a whole new level
of performance.
Now,
we're talking
about power
because all systems
built today
are constrained
by power consumption,
thermals,
or both.
Among today's
consumer systems,
desktops deliver
the highest performance
but consume
the most power.
Notebooks trade
off performance
for lower power,
making them portable.
As you can see,
normally to get
more performance,
you have to consume
more power.
When you take
a closer look
at this chart,
you realize
you want to operate
in the upper left corner.
You want to deliver
the lowest power consumption.
And that's exactly
where we want
to take the Mac.
Building upon
our years of experience,
designing the world's
most energy efficient chips,
our plan is
to give the Mac
a much higher level
of performance
while at the same time
consuming less power.
So,
much better performance
is needed
enough to transition
the Mac
to Apple SoCs.
But that's just
part of the story.
Our scalable architecture
includes many
custom technologies
that,
when integrated
with our software,
will bring
even more innovation
to the Mac.
With our advanced
power management,
we maximize
performance
and battery life
better than ever before.
Our secure enclave
will bring
best-in-class security
and our high-performance
GPU is going
to bring
a whole new level
of graphics performance
to every Mac,
making them
even better
for pro applications
and really great
for games.
And combined
with our neural engines,
our chips
will make the Mac
an amazing platform
for machine learning.
And we're bringing
many other custom
technologies,
such as our video
display and image
processing engines
that will help
make the Mac
better than ever
before.
So what does
all of this mean
for the Mac?
First,
we're designing
a family of SoCs
specifically
for the Mac
product line.
Second,
just like we did
with the iPhone,
iPad and watch,
we're going to bring
great technologies
to the Mac.
This will give
the Mac a unique
set of features
and incredible
performance.
This will make it
far easier
for developers
to write and optimize
software
for the entire
Apple ecosystem.
Ultimately,
we know that bringing
our SoCs to the Mac
will allow us
to build much
better products.
And the Mac
will take another
huge leap forward.
Now,
a key advantage
we have
is the tight integration
of our silicon
with our software.
To tell you more
about how Mac OS
will run on Apple SoCs,
here's my colleague,
Fred.
Thanks, Johnny.
Now,
let's talk
about the technologies
that we built into
Mac OS Big Sur
that will make
the transition
to Apple Silicon
for both consumers
and developers.
These new Mac systems
will be incredible.
And users
will want
their favorite apps
to take full advantage
of the capabilities
of our custom silicon.
And the best way
to do that
is with native apps.
So, of course,
when we updated
our apps for Big Sur,
we built everything
as native
for Apple Silicon.
And I'm happy
to say
we have all
of our own
Apple apps,
including our most demanding
pro apps
like Final Cut Pro
and Logic Pro
up and running
as native now
and will be ready
for customers
on day one.
So how did we do this?
We're using Xcode,
just like all
our developers will.
Everything
developers need
to build apps
for these new chips
is built into
the new version
of Xcode.
To get started,
developers just open
their app projects
and recompile.
The vast majority
of developers
have apps up
and running
in just a matter
of days.
And to deliver
these apps,
we've created
Universal 2.
It's a new type
of universal binary
that works on both
Intel-based Macs
and Macs built
on Apple Silicon.
So developers
can tap into
the native power
and performance
of our new Macs
and still support
Intel-based Macs
all with a single
binary
for all of their users.
Some of the biggest
Mac developers
have already
gotten started.
Microsoft started
working on Office
and we've been working
with Adobe
on their flagship
Creative Cloud
and many of their apps
are already up
and running great.
So let's take a look
at macOS running
on Apple Silicon.
So here we are
on the desktop
that we know
and love
and I'm just going
to open up
about this Mac.
And what you see
here is that
we are running
on our Apple
development platform.
This is a system
built to support
early development
using the same
A12Z processor
currently shipping
in Apple Silicon.
Currently shipping
in iPad Pro.
Now,
I have a confession
to make.
This isn't the first time
you've seen MacOS
running here.
In fact,
this is the same Mac
that Beth and I
used to demo
all the new
Big Sur features
earlier.
And as you saw
earlier,
we've updated
all of our Apple apps
and they're running
great.
Of course,
a big part
of the Mac experience
is third party apps
and we've been working
with our friends
at Microsoft
and they already
have Office
on our new Macs.
Let's take a look
at Word.
Friends from Microsoft.
It runs great.
Scrolling is super smooth.
Everything you do
is just super responsive.
E is as Word.
Next,
let's check out
Excel.
Just as you'd expect,
complex sheets
and elements
like this Mac
all update instantly.
And next,
let's take a look
at PowerPoint.
It's using
Metal for rendering
and it performs
great.
For instance,
check out
how I can see
all the layers
of my slide
in 3D.
The animation
is perfectly fluid.
I've also been working
closely with
our friends
at Adobe
to bring
cleanly
the cloud
to the Mac.
There's Lightroom
running native
on Apple Silicon.
Navigating
large libraries
of DNG images
is super fast
and all
of Lightroom's
editing controls
are available
right here.
Let's apply
an adjustment
to this image.
Ah,
excellent.
So hätte ich
das auch
editiert.
All new Photoshop.
Okay,
gut,
dass Photoshop
geht.
Oh,
oh,
Sie können sogar animierte Titel und Lens-Fläche hinzufügen.
All das während des Live-Playbacks.
Und Final Cut nimmt die unikablen Fähigkeiten des Apple Neural Engine vor,
mit einer neuen Fähigkeit, die Video analysiert und es intelligent kropft,
um die wichtigste Aktion im Frame zu halten.
Aber das ist nicht alles.
Final Cut verfolgt die Multicore-Architektur des Systems,
um nicht nur ein oder zwei, sondern drei Streams von vollem Resolution 4K ProRes zu spielen.
Alle auf einem A12Z-Prozessor.
Unglaublich.
Also das ist ein erster Blick auf universelle Apps auf Apple Silicon.
Wir sind wirklich gespannt auf diese tollen Arbeiten.
Diese Apps werden immer mehr unglaublich, wenn sie gebaut werden,
um die kraftvollen Fähigkeiten des Silicon zu verwenden.
Wie seine unglaubliche CPU- und Grafik-Bewegung.
Eine unifizierte Erinnerungsarchitektur.
Und die Neural Engine zentriert advanced machine learning tasks.
Die Transition zu Apple Silicon ist auch großartig für Entwickler,
die sich für die Erkennung einer neuen Technologie interessieren.
Wir haben bereits ihre Apps für andere Apple-Plattformen optimiert.
Die gemeinsame Architektur unserer Produkte bedeutet,
dass ihr Code absolut gleich sein wird.
Ja, gucken wir uns gleich danach an.
Und es gibt noch mehr zu der Geschichte.
Wir machen einige wirklich wichtige Dinge,
um diese Transition für unsere Benutzer sinnlos zu machen.
Während wir erwarten, dass die meisten Entwickler sofort native werden,
wollen wir sicher machen, dass die Benutzer alle ihre Apps am Tag 1 runtern können,
auch wenn einige Apps noch nicht geupdatet sind.
Wir sind schon auf dieser Straße.
Was habe ich da gerade gesehen?
Vor allem bei Workstation für Mac oder?
You have a system that can run an amazing diversity of apps.
To show you how this all comes together, I'll hand it over to Andreas Wenker.
Nee, das heißt ja nicht, vor allem bei Workstation.
Wie heißt das nochmal unter Mac?
Ähm, hab vergessen.
Für Fusion, Fusion.
Rosetta of course works great with all sorts of apps that use every day.
But for our first demo, I'd like to show you something a bit more challenging.
This is Maya, the powerfulazer pug,
animation and modeling software running great here on apple silicon i already have a model
open that consists of over six million polygons we are all sitting in one boat move around in this
scene so let's make a little more challenging and bring in textures and shaders as well
and still everything is incredibly fluid so rosetta works great and the performance is
simply fantastic but rosetta isn't just for apps it also works amazingly well with games
i can even use a game controller this is shadow of the tomb raider a high-end aaa game that's
using our metal apis i downloaded directly from the mac app store so it's completely unmodified
and it is absolutely beautiful let me jump into the water you can see some of the lighting
effects here and as i follow the path you can see the game is responsive it's smooth
and the best part is we're running it at 1080p as a translated app under emulation
so these new macs they are fast just because you can hear that they come from germany we are the only ones
who can get over it somehow he speaks great english better than we will ever do
most of them including me and chat you can see the graphical user interface designed for linux here
but of course many developers like to use linux for hosting service yes that's right
and launch an apache web server is that ubuntu and now
i can simply bring up safari
excellent
i can use fender play
yeah man can relax at the end of the day back to you craig
thanks andreas as you saw max built with apple silicon will be able to run iphone and ipad
apps directly starting day one users can download these apps right from the mac app store and
most apps will just work with no changes from the developer with everything we're doing the range of
apps that users will be able to run on these new macs is truly unprecedented together we have all
the technologies in place to make this an amazing transition the vast majority of mac apps can be
recompiled as universal in a few days so users can have fast native apps rosetta 2 provides even more easy-to-use apps.
this amazing transition the vast majority of mac apps can be recompiled as universal in a few days so users can have fast native apps rosetta 2 can be compiled as universal in a few days so users can have fast native apps
Es ist ja nicht Cross-Compile, diese Rosetta-2-Geschichte, das ist echt cool.
Das ist nicht einfach, sowas zu basteln.
Wow.
Sowas brauche ich.
Apple, Apple, ich streame auch eine halbe Stunde davon, das sollte doch reichen, oder?
Was?
Benchmarks gibt es nicht.
Oh.
Ja.
Okay.
Jetzt doch.
Ich glaube, das ist dem erst, wenn es wirklich zwei Jahre gibt.
Okay.
Das muss man Apple lassen, die sind immer sehr fix mit sowas.
So, let's have a great WWDC.
Was?
Alter, ihr habt Probleme.
Äh, Mixer.
Wir müssen uns die News von Mixer angucken.
Ja, Microsoft is shutting down Mixer.
Ich hab's euch gesagt.
Mixer, Mixer, Mixer, komm weg.
Microsoft is shutting down Mixer
and partnering with Facebook Gaming.
Forget...
Leute, gut, dass wir auf Twitch sind.
Gut, dass wir auf Twitch sind.
Jetzt kommt als nächstes
MySpace.
MySpace Gaming.
Gut, dass wir auf Twitch sind.
Ich frag mich jetzt nur,
was Ninja und Shroud machen.
Weil,
die sind ja erst weg.
Okay, Ninja früher und
Shroud ein bisschen später.
Gehen die jetzt zurück nach Twitch
und lassen sich da erstmal auslachen?
Was ist das?
Ein großer Streamer
streamt auf Twitch und ist am Flamen.
Okay, warte mal, das müssen wir uns mal angucken.
Warte mal,
schauen wir mal kurz auf.
Darf ich hier überhaupt Mixer-Content zeigen?
Oh, oh, Leute, Achtung, Achtung.
Fuck you, Mixer.
Null.
Oh, der ist, der ist stinkig.
Twitch TV X-Mister dran.
Oh Gott.
Oh, das war bloß, das war bloß, das war bloß, das war bloß, das war bloß...
Oh, ich bin ein Schwachsinn, ich bin ein Schwachsinn.
Ich kann echt nicht.
Du kennst doch nichts.
Du kennst doch nichts aus.
Dein einziger Titel,
der hatte richtig viel Erfolg auf Twitch.
Ich fand das total gut.
Ich fand es echt gut.
Ich hab sie wirklich ausgesucht.
Ich hab es immer in meinem Kopf geklaut.
Das ist wirklich, das ist das,
was ich hier jetzt gesagt habe,
im Blick auf, was ich jetzt sage.
Das ist wirklich,
den Halt, den ich vorhabe,
ist das, was sie jetzt gerade gesagt hat.
Die ganze Zeit.
Das ist, was sie jetzt sagen hat,
Und sieht mal, wie viele Follower er hat.
Ich blick auf Mixer nicht durch.
Hier, 11.000.
Der hätte auf Twitch wahrscheinlich mehr.
Oh, der ist pisst, Alter.
Der ist pisst.
Geh auf...
Alter, komm zu Twitch.
Beste.
Warum ist eigentlich die Seite
vom Mixer so kaputt?
Geil.
Mixer.
Das war's.
Geil.
RIP.
Was macht Ninja so?
Ninja, Shroud
and other tops
are now free to stream on Twitch again.
Okay, Ninja hat
Ninja und Shroud
haben den
Deal ihres Lebens gemacht.
Was es da an Millionen gegeben hat.
Und können wieder zurück auf Twitch.
Was Besseres kann es da ja eigentlich gar nicht geben.
Oh, in einem Monat
machen die schon dicht.
Okay, ich muss jetzt nochmal auf Mixer kurz gucken,
wie viele Leute da am Flamen sind.
Die haben garantiert keine Mixer-Anteile bekommen.
Goodbye, Mixer.
RIP.
Gut, dass wir auf Twitch sind.
Gut, dass wir auf Twitch sind, Leute.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ohne Spaß, Leute.
Excellent.
Da freue ich mich ja richtig, dass ich auf Twitch angefangen habe.
Moment, gucken wir mal.
Ninja.
About.
Streams, Valorant and Fortnite.
Moment, hat der schon
sein Twitch-Profil geupdatet?
Hat der sein Twitch-Profil
schon geupdatet?
Was?
Hahaha.
Der war aber schnell.
Wie sieht es bei Shroud aus?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ninja, Mixer.
Ist der gerade online auf Mixer?
No stream updates.
Updates soon. Verstehe, verstehe.
I really hope I come back.
Mixer is shutting down.
Was? Shroud?
Gucken.
Please come back.
Twitch.
Look at his Twitch chat right now.
Oh.
Haha, so geil.
Wie sieht es sich...
Was?
Sub...
Da wird aktiv moderiert auf Shroud auf Twitch.
Sub mode.
Gell.
Ja, nice.
Oh man.
Damit hätte ich jetzt...
Also mit der...
Mit der Meldung hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet, dass das Mixer im Arsch ist.
Ich meine, Facebook Gaming.
Wie sieht...
Ich habe das noch nie gesehen.
Wie sieht das überhaupt aus?
Das ist ja reudig.
Wer gibt sich denn sowas?
PUBG Mobile.
Hier sieht man doch nicht mal, wie viel die Leute gucken.
Browse Streamers.
Okay, wo gucken die meisten Leute gerade zu?
Ich will gucken, wo die meisten Leute gerade zugucken.
Wo sieht man...
Kann man das überhaupt sortieren?
Wie sortiere ich nach Streamer auf dieser Kackseite überhaupt?
Ich weiß doch nicht mal, wie ich die Seite bediene.
Oh, E-Sports-Events.
Rainbow Six, 26 Zuschauer.
Excellent.
Browse Games.
Okay, anscheinend ist auf...
Die Seite ist lahm.
Es...
Fuck.
Guckt euch das mal an, hier.
PUBG Mobile.
100...
107 Zuschauer.
Und der nächste 3.
Perfekt.
Das ist die Zukunft.
Leute, bin ich froh, dass wir auf Twitch sind.
Man kann auf Twitch rumhaten, wie man lustig ist.
Es sind vielleicht auch Sachen in der TOS-Auslegung und sowas nicht so ganz klar.
Aber selbst seit...
Also, gerade seit der Amazon-Übernahme hat sich auch vieles verbessert.
Seitdem die Zugriff auf die Amazon-Infrastruktur haben.
Twitch ist deutlich weniger ausgelassen, hat weniger...
Kackt weniger ab.
Es gibt ein paar Sachen, wie diese...
Diese Copyright-Geschichte jetzt.
Und auch die ganzen Diskussionen, die da teilweise geführt werden.
Die früher kein Thema waren.
Also...
Hat sich nicht alles zum Besseren gewendet.
Aber man kann sagen, Twitch ist immer noch die beste Plattform, wenn man Livestreams machen will.
Gerade für Gaming und mittlerweile auch für andere Sachen.
Twitch ist immer noch das Beste.
Twitch leidet ein bisschen unter ihrem Erfolg, wenn man es so will.
Weil umso mainstreamiger Plattformen werden...
Umso mehr...
Ja, müssen sie sich auch anpassen.
Tja.
YouTube-Livestream finde ich total eklig.
JustinTV, ja.
Das sind ja...
Da sind ja die Ursprünge von hier.
Die Kappa-Ursprünge waren ja JustinTV.
Ich fände es witzig, dass Ninja schon seinen Stream angepasst hat.
Und ich würde mich kaputtlachen, wenn Shroud jetzt einfach auf...
Auf...
Ähm...
Twitch online kommt.
Oder auch, wenn Ninja einfach auf Twitch online kommt.
Dann lache ich mich kaputt, ey.
TikTok Gaming...
Oh, das kann ich mir tatsächlich vorstellen.
Der Kram wird ja mehr benutzt, als man so denkt.
Als man so denkt.
Na, der Chat bei Shroud ist ja leider...
Ah, die haben Submode only ausgemacht.
We back, we back.
Die Leute sind voll am ausrasten, Alter.
Die Leute sind voll am ausrasten.
Guckt es euch an.
Die drehten, die eskalieren voll.
Now is Subscriber Mode.
Warum?
Okay, Leute.
Ich muss jetzt dringend was essen.
Ähm...
Und morgen muss ich wieder arbeiten gehen.
Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
See you.